I want to thank you for coming I want to
thank you for being brave and coming in
in spite of all of the rhetoric and the
hateful islamophobic anti-muslim bigotry
narrative that we get smeared with all
the time so first and foremost thank you
I'm thrilled that you're here
thank you um I want to thank the Hyatt
yes
yes for those of you that don't know the
story very briefly I was speaking
supposed to speak at the H in Sugarland
and uh you know a couple of thugs made a
couple phone calls and they canceled me
and you every activist and every single
one of you are an activist work the
phones sent letters some of you even
sold your stock God love
you and it became such a a a brewhaha
that not only did I get to speak that
night elsewhere we spoke to double the
amount that we originally I think we
spoke to 400 and I was supposed to speak
to originally 200 and the Hyatt
apologized profusely and said they would
give me space in Sugar L but I said well
I spoke there already they said we'll
give you space anywhere in America I
said great I want to space India born
so kudos to them for apologizing and I
think this room is is just fabulous I
think it's just great and I again I
thank them profusely um it's very
important that we are here today it's
very important that we increase
awareness of honor killings you see as
soon as we raise this subject
immediately the knee-jerk reaction of
hate intolerance bigotry and so on and
so forth why
to shut it down
ASAP I understand there was a rally
today an anti- Geller anti- Spencer
rally another words it was called
backlash
phobia um and it was a it was a a
fundraising what thanks much to to to
OLG who was there a stealth fundraiser
where they paint us as uh you know fear
mongers that we're raising money I don't
do I have to tell you what security cost
here just to tell you just to talk to
you about this
message why aren't they speaking out
against honor killings I am asking you
why are they not standing up here with
me they made some wise crack that tell
Pamela Geller uh not to stand up for the
Muslim girls in America but to stand up
for the Muslim girls in Palestine well
just for knowing I am standing up and
there is no Palestine I am standing up
for the Muslim girls well there's not I
mean come
on I am standing up for the Muslim girls
in Gaza and Sam Mara and Judea who by
the way are hon a slaughtered that you
never hear about the very idea that
they're saying that there is no honor
killing shows that complete contempt for
your intelligence quotient we know you
know according to the Reliance of the
traveler
584 the sanctioning of the killing of
Offspring but it's not just that we are
talking about the murder of thousands of
girls this girl Jessica moad who was
onor murdered a year ago not far from
here lived an abject fear of her life
her friend Darwin Giles who should be
speaking today will tell you she feared
being honor killed and she went from one
household to another because they both
were trying to impose Islamic tradition
on her these girls deserve the same
freedoms and the same rights to choose
as every other
American every single one
rights equal life the right to live the
right to pursue your happiness this is a
basic fundamental
unquestionable right in America and I'm
being derided and smeared and defamed
and I'm getting I'm getting rich oh
really will someone give me the bank
vault key CU I haven't seen it yet this
takes an extraordinary amount of money
and courage and work and you are defamed
and you are smeared for standing up for
basic fundamental right and I will tell
you that law enforcement needs education
you see now you see the prosecutor
contaldo who originally in April of 2011
said she was killed because she was too
Western she was killed because her
stepfather felt that she was uh not
Islamic enough and you see in every news
story every single one now he's saying
no it was not it was that he was
obsessed with her it was about power it
was a control he wanted her sexually
well FYI that's part of honor
killing Amina and Sarah SED Amina and
Sarah SED were raped when they were
seven and8 in
Texas who speaks for Amina and Sarah
they lead two lives they lead the life
in school the Western life and the life
of a Muslim girl who's abused terrorized
at home it's gender
terrorism terrorized you don't even know
you just hear about the killing you
don't hear about what went on that led
up to the Final Act of
control because she shamed the family
and you heard in Canada and I'm sure Mr
Corin uh will will embellish upon it uh
the father said the girls he killed his
three daughters and the aunt who was
really his first wife but polygamy as
you know under Islam is allowed for Mass
honor Su killings and the father said
that they had betrayed Islam May the the
devil I'll use a more polite word
defecate on their
graves what what more do we need why are
we not why are we not allowed to talk
about this why are we not allowed to
talk about the dehumanization and
diminishment of women under Islam how
many girls have to die you see in the UK
which is much further along they have a
forced marriage unit they have a
national H hotline they get thousands of
calls a month we need a national hotline
because unlike a battered spouse who has
to get away from the
husband these girls have such an
incredibly difficult Journey you can't
possibly know how alone they are non
darsh her family will not talk to her at
all none of
them you have to leave the family you
have to leave the community you have to
leave the mosque many times like riff
gabari the Christian convert out of
Islam The Mask spied on her told her
parents she left Islam she was hiding it
for 4 years four years years they
threatened to kill her and look what the
media did to her look what the N media
did to
her made her out to be some crazy
Christian fundamentalist radical I don't
even know what that means so if you have
Jesus in your heart you're a Christian
fundamentalist radical I never saw
anybody blowing themselves up yelling
you know uh Jesus
abbar ever I never saw anyone ever kill
in the name of Hashem or in the Name of
Christ
ever we have to be able to say these
things there's no there's no there's no
critical analysis in Islam
ever honor killings is a problem and I'm
going to tell you that I'm not going to
shut up about it because these girls
deserve every shot every opportunity
there must be a safety net law
enforcement must be made aware that they
cannot return these girls to their home
can't there has to be special help
centers for them shelters where you
don't contact the family because as soon
as you contact the family she's she's
finished
we don't even know how many girls
disappear why because who reports when a
young girl disappears from a family who
reports it the
family we need to start tracking honor
killings there is no way to track honor
killings I mean I have tried in so many
different ways to cross reference okay
how many it's got to be state by state
how many girls died how are they Muslim
how old were they usually 15 to 24 but
Muslim wives have a very hard time and
so on and so forth Asia Hassan married
to a moderate Muslim who started a
television station called Bridges a
bridge from Islam to to the west and he
was abusing her for years and the
community knew the community knew
because she was you know living a
western life and when she finally left
and fall for
divorce he took a sword off the wall and
cut her head
off this is an Abomination this is
monstrous do not be afraid you must
speak up you must look in your community
you are the ones you are here that's a
huge first First Step but I don't want
to hog the m i don't want to hog the M
there's a lot I would like to say about
91% of the honor killings across the
world are Islamic 91% so if you got rid
of 91% look how look how far we would go
and in the west it's it's it's much more
than that and what they don't tell you
is about the suicides how many suicides
there are in 2007 alone in England to uh
um 270 women threw themselves in front
of a train many with their Muslim
children just to get out of the shame
because it's part of their psyche too
rear they're reared on it they've shamed
the family also it's horri it's horrible
this honor code and we must speak
against it and we cannot respect it as
Obama would
say we have to marginalize it parias
eyesee it and make it absolutely
forbidden
forbidden in this
country okay now what I'd like to do
next is I'd like you to hear
just to get this out of the way I know I
don't have to but I'd like you to hear
from Darwin Giles Darwin Giles was
Jessica mad's extremely close friend as
a matter of fact he too feared for his
safety when she came to him looking for
escape and I'd like you to hear from him
because he is the most reliable witness
when you hear from the family when you
hear from the family the stepmother who
by the way is the same age as Jessica
hello and who did not get along with
Jessica they did not get along and both
households were oppressing her so we
have to listen to the family that was
complicit in her in her murder all
families are co-conspirators and Anor
murders in the UK they prosecute the
family there is legislation to prosecute
this family and that's what we have to
pass legislation here we have to pass
female genital mutilation laws they're
trying to pass it and according to
someone who was talking to a lawmaker
they said that that law against female
General mutilation was an attack on the
Islamic community
really that rally earli today against
this was a pro honor killing rally
that's what that was because if you're
covering up for that you're supporting
it anybody that opposes this work
supports the Sharia right now I'd like
to turn the mic over to Darwin
[Applause]
Giles hello everyone
I would like to start first and just
thank if we could give uh Mrs Pamela and
David Woods and everyone involved who
actually allowed me to have the
opportunity to express uh the
convictions and also just the secret
information and private conversations
and and also relationship that I had
with Jessica um I just if we could just
give her a hand and just really uh let
her know we really appreciate
that I actually knew Jessica now going
on close to two and a half three years
uh from the very first time I actually
met her um you know from the from the
surface she seemed as if she was very
happy uh but that soon changed uh she
started to tell me uh after meeting her
uh about the issues with the head
covering uh she started to tell me about
the issues with how her mother and also
her stepfather uh would basically have
uh some serious power struggles with her
and how her family started to feel that
she was a re a rebel uh against Islam
she was a young lady who wanted Freedom
she wanted to uh date outside of her her
race she wanted to date even outside of
her ethnicity or religion she wanted to
discover God even for herself uh but she
was not given that opportunity uh she
was an individual who uh after talking
to her for I would say even hours on the
phone at times the majority of our
conversation was was concerning uh the
oppression she faced at home uh and
being from the Western Society I really
didn't understand besides a textbook
about Islam I knew the penalties for
certain things but I never personally
experienced it myself and two I actually
had the privilege of meeting Jessica um
and what she would tell me uh really
from myself uh had me concerned about my
own personal safety uh she would almost
uh literally have to in secret meet up
with me she would literally uh call me
and and just be in downright guilt uh
about the head covering and how you know
she really wanted to discover God first
self but these these pressures and
different things and Customs that was
passed down from her parents uh it
really began to have her in a depressed
state um I never personally witnessed
anyone like this until now now so I know
that the terror that these young ladies
live in is real and I would also
encourage anyone to really also research
Lena Muhammad who just recently uh
passed away as well and they're thinking
this could possibly another honor
killing um Jessica was someone that
would would really I mean at any time
she would want to uh you know Express
you know just her personally opinions
about God in several different things
and giving the fact that you know they
were pretty much forcing her to leave
and move out of state and we kept in
contact even when she left and even when
she came back and one thing that would
would really stick out to me is just
really on how she was in
fear she was in fear of even moving away
to a degree of she wanted to please her
her biological father and because of the
relationships with her father's side uh
there was a such a power struggle with
the daughter because they were the exact
same age um she would almost make her
feel as if she was shameful as if she
was somewhat dirty for wanting to uh you
know basically be culturalized with the
Wern Society um she this wasn't a cover
up um if I had two words to say about
the situation it would be conspiracy and
cover up um when I heard that the actual
videotapes from the Stepmom I was just
completely uh literally just in shame
about the situ situation in the matter
because I personally heard this young
lady's cries I heard of how she felt she
wasn't equal uh and how she felt that if
she didn't live a certain lifestyle
according to Islam that she could
possibly be hurt so when I first heard
that her she actually died in the just
the horrible way that she did uh the
first thing that came to mind was you
know all the times that she would talk
to me and would be in fear so the first
thing I said to myself is wow what she
actually feared really happened what she
actually feared would happen to her it
really happened she had she she she
almost felt by leaving that there would
be some type of difference or change but
once there was more pressure for her to
wear the head covering she would send
text messages out almost in secret
because she wanted people to see that
she didn't want to wear the head
covering she didn't she didn't want to
uh be forced into the customs of Islam
and so actually with with getting this I
seen the hurt I seen the outcry from her
and I just really appreciate everyone
for being able to hear this story uh
this is not anything anyone is trying to
personally uh receive any any type of
gain we just want the truth to be out
about her story we just want the truth
to be out about Islam and just her life
uh even since I've basically spoke out
about this I've received personal death
threats um I've had individuals who have
wanted to try to of any way intimidate
me I've even was deleted off of her
Facebook page in block from the things
that I I basically posted from knowing
her so I've actually just experiencing
this I I just really cons I I would ask
everyone to really have a true and
honest open ear but more importantly
once you hear the truth to take up and
take a serious stand against uh what's
happening because these young ladies
really they they don't have any Outlet
uh their families are covering up the
truth and and we are the ones that's
going to have to make a serious
difference so I just want to thank
everyone thank you very much that's
really why we're here that's why we're
doing this we're trying to call
attention to a tremendous human rights
abuse that is being almost completely
ignored and I will be very brief uh I am
Robert Spencer from Jihad watch and uh
thanks we have a we have a full roster
of speakers here today and so I just
wanted to expand on a couple of things
that Pamela said earlier uh you all know
of course that the uh media is spinning
this as a uh an exercise in hatred and
islamophobia and that uh the earlier
conference that was held today is uh
claiming that uh we are blaming Islam
for something that has nothing to do
with Islam and Pamela has already
touched on this in uh saying that
pointing out that 91% of all honor
killing are done by Muslims and among
Muslims and that that is no accident it
is in a manual of Islamic law Reliance
of the traveler orik that is actually
certified by alar University which is
the foremost authority in Sunni Islam
and Sunni Muslims are 85 to 90% of all
Muslims worldwide and this Manual of
Islamic law is certified as being a
reliable guide to what Islam is and it
says in there that there is no
retaliation for a parent who kills a
child there is no
penalty not only that Jordan Syria
Palestinian Authority Iraq and elsewhere
if you kill somebody then you have the
various uh kinds of punishments that
Prevail around the world but if you can
prove that it was an honor killing you
get off
lightly and in Jordan the Jordanian
Parliament actually several years ago
tried to stiffen penalties for honor
killings and it was Islamic clarity
who opposed this measure and ultimately
defeated it saying that it would weaken
the
family we have to face the facts that if
we're going to defend the human rights
of these girls who are threatened then
we have to face that this is an Islamic
problem and this does not mean that
every Muslim in the world is going to
kill his daughter but the justifications
for this practice are in Islamic law and
that is why 91% of honor killings take
place among Muslims and unless and until
we face that and unless and until we
call upon the Muslim Community in the
United States and worldwide to face it
more girls are going to
die and so it's all very well for the
Imam at the Islamic Center of America in
Dearborn to say well Pamela Geller is
the problem and she spreading
islamophobia but what he is doing is
exactly what she said it was it is pro-
honor killing it is in defense of Honor
killing because by standing up against
those of us who are trying to call
attention to this barbarity and to end
it and making us into the problem he is
doing nothing but running interference
for Honor
murder and So Pro honor killing is
exactly the right term for those who
have come out in opposition to what
we're doing here
today this is not a problem that is of
stigmatizing IND individuals this is a
problem of a legal code that threatens
individuals and so with more and direct
testimony about how that happens I very
honored now to introduce Noni Darwish an
exus Muslim who grew up and was taught
the same kind of hatred and violence
that leads to honor
killing thank you very much uh I want to
thank Pamela and uh Robert very much for
believing in us for uh really you
know championing this this cause because
few Americans are doing that they are
heroes for me I lived it I
lived I was born and raised as a Muslim
in Cairo Egypt I grew up in the Gaza
Strip and I uh I personally knew a girl
who was 16 who was honor killed uh she
was our maid she came to our home uh
having a maid is a very common thing in
in the Muslim world and they're treated
like slaves practically unfortunately
and uh my mom noticed that she was
pregnant and this is unheard of nobody
ever in the Muslim world can can have a
baby out of wedlock so she she got a a
nurse to check her out and and uh she
she found out she was pregnant she asked
her how did you what happened and she
said the house she was in before coming
to us the man uh the husband was raping
her uh a lot and finally his wife caught
them she kicked her out of the house at
2:00 a.m. in the street telling her that
you're seducing my husband it's your
fault even though she was being raped at
that time she was
15 and my mom didn't want to send her to
her family because she knew they were
going to kill her you see even if you're
raped you have become a useless uh uh
you know Untouchable dirty a dirty girl
even if you're raped so she sent her to
a government agency and uh a year later
the uh the agent who brought her to us
we asked him what what happened to her
and I can never forget her face I
because I was her age at that time I was
also
16 and he said to my mom asked him how
is she and she she he told her in
Arabic in Arabic when you ask somebody
how is so and so and they die they tell
them in Arabic um may God prolong your
life Madam it means that she died so she
we all got shocked what happened and he
said her father and brother after she
delivered she was sent went back to them
and they took care of her
disgrace they didn't go to the husband
who was raping her the adult man who was
raping her no they killed the
girl I I believe it or not we heard that
no one called the
police no no nobody thought it was a
crime because I grew up watching Arabic
movies where where girls uh who have
have had sex outside of marriage in the
movie Always either were
killed they or had an accident or God
struck them or they drowned something
bad happened so I grew up with with this
notion that if I ever uh not only have
sex outside of marriage even talk to a
man it's a big crime it's and I am
always at fault a Muslim woman is always
at fault because they give you the
ression that you're seducing men just by
being who you
are so it's always the woman's fault
it's always the girls fault and that's
why they kill the
girls 5,000 women and girls are honor
killed in the Middle East every year and
those are the reported cases and this
fact is enough to send the message to
all Muslim women not only and even if
you're a minority who's non Muslim who
lives in the Middle East you get you get
influenced by that the message is you
better abide by Shar or
else and it affects us all we give in we
we become
doormats we have no rights and we give
in and that is the tragedy and I want to
tell you that we had also um somebody
from a village that used to tell us
stories about bodies flowing in the Nile
of
girls and even the the little village uh
the little V The Village sheriff or he
wouldn't even report there's a body of a
girl floating in the
Nile the kids will be playing and seeing
one body floating and they just look at
it till it
disappears and everybody would say see
what happened to the girls who have
misbehaved
sexually nothing is reported nothing no
penalty no search who is she no search
who killed her and that's why I'm saying
if 5,000 are reported there's another at
least 5,000 I'll I'll
reported
and I want to tell you something I lived
in the Middle East for 30 years of my
life I have never heard a Muslim shikh
give a sermon in the
mosque in no no uh no unequivocal terms
condemning honor killing as
unlam to the country Sheik supported
honor killings they never spoke against
it they never said it's un Islamic I
have heard all this only in America
there is a double face of Islam there is
the face of Islam that's being
propagandized in
America as moderate and peaceful and
there's the Real Islam that I grew up
with in the Muslim world and they are
two worlds
apart and I don't want the West I don't
want America to be fooled by this
propaganda they are they have closed
their society totally for you to go live
in the Muslim world you're an Infidel
you cannot go live there but we have
opened they have nothing to lose we have
everything to lose we have welcomed a
whole culture and there is they grow
very rapidly we have welcomed a whole
culture and we have everything to lose
if we don't stand up quickly today
before it's too late and make Sharia an
illegal uh by name an illegal uh and
archaic and demonic legal system that
must be abolished from the face of the
Earth no ladies and gentlemen Sharia law
is not a cultural thing it is a legal
system it's part of the Islamic legal
system it's part of the culture it's
part of the way of life and every Muslim
girl is a of it this uh this young man
talking about her he when he talked
about her he reminded he reminded my me
I felt he was ex you know H when I was
her age that's how I felt in the Muslim
world so this is not something uh
uncommon this is common it took me years
to get rid of my fear it took me years
to learn to be have dignity as a woman
and to develop my self-esteem as a woman
and thank you America for for giving me
that freedom and that dignity and God
bless America thank you very
much thank you
n it is
uh really breathtaking when we hear
stories like that to think that that
this is the country that is the Bastion
and the beacon of freedom in the world
and everybody's trying to get here and
meanwhile those of us who are here are
doing everything that we can to
accommodate the enemies of freedom and
to throw it all
away anyway with a firsthand story of
that it is now my great pleasure and
honor to introduce David wood of act 17
apologetics a very courageous Christian
evangelist
who will give you a harrowing firsthand
account of exactly how freedom is being
lost in America
today thank you Robert and I'm glad to
see so many people come out here tonight
and I'm honored to be on the same panel
uh with several people who happen to be
my heroes and I don't toss that around
as a term of flattery um I I'm if you
don't know
why maybe you're with the media and you
don't know why I would consider these
people Heroes um for those of you who
are up here on stage uh raise your hand
if you've been threatened with brutal
death for what you
do um raise your hand if you've been
threatened more than a 100
times
500 well we sto
[Laughter]
counting and yet and yet they're bigoted
hate mongers for thinking that uh
they're dealing with an A Dangerous
ideology uh you don't do what they do
unless you are so concerned for other
people and for freedom and human rights
that you're willing to lay down your
life and that my friends is the
definition of heroic
Behavior
so there are basically two sides here to
the Sharia debate there are people who
like me don't ever want to see Sharia or
Islamic law influence uh laws in the
west and on the other side are people
who say hey it's not it's it's it's not
much of a threat it's not something to
worry about now I I I'll speak for
myself here my concerns about Sharia are
based almost entirely on what Sharia
actually says what's actually in the
sources so I open up the Quran and I
read Surah 9:29 fight those who do not
believe in Allah not fight in self-de
defense fight people who do not believe
it's fighting People based on their
beliefs I turn to Surah 551 do not be
friends with Jews and Christians they
are friends of each other you choose
your friends based on their religious
beliefs Surah
48:29 those who are with Muhammad are
severe against who against disbelievers
merciful among who among themselves as a
Muslim you are commanded to be merciful
towards your fellow Muslims not to the
unbeliever open up Surah 3 ver
110 what's it say who're the best people
in the world Muslims what about Jews and
Christians you turn to sah 986 Jews and
Christians who reject the truth of Islam
are the worst of creatures we're lower
than rats it doesn't take a genius to
look at these teachings and say if you
get enough people believing that this is
the actual word of God you're going to
run into some conflicts with things like
the First Amendment of the Constitution
of the United
States and yet we're told no it's no
threat whatsoever and I think that the
people who who who disagree with me
they're not disagreeing based on what
Islam teaches right if they if they read
the sources they'll see what Islam
teaches I think their argument goes
something like this David if Islamic law
were dangerous then all Muslims would be
dangerous and yet I know many peaceful
Muslims and since there are so many
peaceful Muslims what they believe
cannot be dangerous and therefore I
don't even need to look at what Islam
teaches I can tell you right now it's
peaceful and tolerant just like uh the
Muslims we have
so who's right here well we get to a
place like Dearborn and it can actually
help us uh learn something because you
see there are plenty of peaceful
tolerant Muslims in Egypt and Iraq and
Pakistan and yet the oppressive rules of
sharia always seem to rise to the
surface in spite of the peaceful
tolerant ones and so what we should be
asking ourselves is not whether there
are peaceful and tolerant Muslims it's
whether here in the west as numbers of
uh Muslims grow if
the oppressive rules of sharia are going
to rise to the surface and here we have
excellent place to examine this issue a
place like the city of
Dearborn I came to Dearborn in 2008 as
part of a group I was uh I was I I was
teaching them about Islam because some
of them are are they're Christian
missionaries Christian evangelists who
don't know a lot necessarily know a lot
about Islam so they're wondering what
Muslims might ask them and what Muslims
might say about their beliefs and uh you
know how they should respond so I was
doing that training and after words we
went out to a mosque in
Dearborn so this is 2008 uh none of you
had ever heard of uh anything with me
and Dearborn there was my first visit we
went to a mosque and we stood on the
public sidewalks and it was interesting
while we were there the mosque was
blasting the sermon over a loudspeaker
over the entire neighborhood blasting
the message I don't care I don't have
any problem with them doing that so
Muslim area goad and blast your message
point is if you're walking down the
street on this public sidewalk you are
going to hear
their message what they have to say and
it's only fair then that other people
should be able to share their message
right United States we have to be equal
here so we tried to hand out some uh
copies of the New Testament some DVDs
not inside the MOs on MOS property on
the public sidewalk so that people would
see us as they're walking home and we
could give them something so we started
handing things out Dearborn police show
up ask us what we're doing round us up
into a little group then then the police
officer starts talking to the uh Imam in
Arabic didn't know what he was saying
and then comes back and says I want all
of your ID cards right now and then he
spends about the next 15 minutes writing
down all of our information all of our
addresses this is kind of intimidating
and meanwhile meanwhile the Imam the
leaders there are Shing everyone home sh
all the Muslims home the people that
we're going to distribute materials to
and so the officer finally let us go and
everyone was gone and so we left and so
think about that if you are a Muslim in
that area you are free to Proclaim your
message to anyone who walks down the
street if you try to proclaim a
different message police were going to
get
involved now at that point I thought
well maybe that's just some weird police
officer or something like that who
doesn't understand that he took an oath
to support and defend the Constitution
of the United
States and I found out things run uh
things are a bit deeper the next year
2009 went to the Arab International
Festival and police the dear Police
Department announced
beforehand no one would be allowed to
distribute materials on the sidewalk
right the in previous prior prior years
uh you could distribute material so you
could go hand out things on the sidewalk
the sidewalk is not part of the festival
the festival is the street on the
sidewalks are still public
sidewalks so the Dearborn Police
Department ruled now you cannot come
down here we will arrest you if you are
Distributing materials on the sidewalk
uh so their reasoning is we're applying
this to everyone so officially there's
nothing wrong with it now if you were at
that Arab festival and some of you were
you walked down that Festival what did
you you walk down that sidewalk what did
you see you saw people handing stuff out
left and right the rule would only be
enforced if you're a Christian you show
up with the Bible That's when hey hey
hey heyy we we we've got a problem here
so think about how brilliant this is the
way to get around the First Amendment of
the Constitution of the United States we
make a rule that applies to everyone but
we happen to be the police so we will
only enforce it on the people we don't
want Distributing materials so since we
weren't allowed to distribute
materials uh we decided to have a
conversation and we we went and had this
conversation based on something that was
happening at the festival you see now
that security had a little muscle behind
them that the deborn police security was
doing something very interesting and
Brilliant I mean it's diabolical but
it's brilliant security is walking up to
Christians who are just there to have
conversations with the Muslims not
Christians who are handing things out it
was still perfectly acceptable to have
conversations but if they saw you
talking to Muslims talking to some young
Muslims trying to share the gospel the
uh Security in plain someone from in
plain clothes would come up to you and
say uh hey I see you have a Bible there
could I take a look at it for just a
second I wanted to look something up as
soon as you turn to hand the Bible
someone was over there click took a
picture come with us you're going to
police and then they go to police you
see right here we have this person on
camera Distributing
Bibles and then you were in trouble and
then you were
scared brilliant plan but uh we actually
went up to a Muslim booth that had a big
sign up there got questions we got
answers we wanted to ask a question
whether they kind of agree with what's
going on because according to Surah
929 uh Muslims are supposed to subjugate
non-muslims and take away their rights
so we want to know if they actually
approve of what's going on there we got
our answer because Security started
slapping us all over the
place and we left that year we came back
to make sure that police who told us
they were going to make sure that ort of
thing didn't happen again we wanted to
make sure that police are going to keep
their end of the bargain so we came back
and you know what happened there of
course we were
arrested uh we were thrown in jail um
and You' you I'm sure you've heard
stories we're screaming at people and
starting a r and so on sorry I was there
we're leaving the festival my friend
Nabil was walking out a group of young
Muslims came up to him started asking
him very good questions they're asking
the sorts of questions we really want to
answer questions like about what
Christians believe and so on questions
about the Bible we love to answer those
questions nail is answering the
questions he's praising uh these young
Muslims for asking these questions
police come up put us all in handcuffs
take us off to jail throw us in jail and
of course later on that's when I hear
the stories that we were screaming at
people and starting a riot and so on
from the lovely mayor of Dearborn May
O'Reilly uh but the most horrifying
aspect of everything that happened for
me wasn't being thrown in jail it's what
we heard while we were there while we
were in the Dearborn jail
a police officer told Nabil and Paul two
of the two of the uh my friends who
arrested um that they agree with us not
all police officers he's saying there
are some of us here who agree with you
and exposing what's going on and you
know Neal pointed out that hey we're
here in jail you know what's going how
can you agree with us and so on and he
said you don't have to tell me I've gone
into houses here in Dearborn where girls
have been killed for having boyfriends
and the department keeps it quiet
I've never heard of any honor killings
here in Dearborn and yet according to a
police officer it's happening and
they're making sure people don't know
about it now could he be lying I guess
it's possible I have no clue why he
would make something like that up
because it's
horrible and so we get out of jail
thinking wow I'm starting to understand
what's going on here and you know that
the whole time though I'm thinking you
know hey this is the police department
it's a problem with the police
department surely when the prosecuting
attorney sees he's going to throw this
out uh wrong wrong this is Dear Boy uh
then I think well once it gets in front
of the judge obviously the judge is
going to throw this out wrong uh they
came after us we had a five-day
trial um and just I'll give you a little
uh little personal um Insight here uh I
have four children I have four boys four
Sons um two of them have genetic
disabilities the disabilities are as bad
as it can possibly be if it was anywhere
You' just be dead as soon as you're born
uh they can't breathe on their own they
can't eat on their own they don't
swallow um they move their arms and
stuff but but that's about it so we have
two our two youngest sons I don't like
leaving my home my wife at home uh with
all four boys uh knowing that she has to
take care of of of all of them uh but
we've agreed I will go out if there's
something important to do it's something
you know that that we both consider
important uh I don't consider a 5-day
ridiculous trial for my friend answering
some questions at a public Festival uh
important so uh this was just horrifying
to me that I'm leaving my wife home to
come here uh for a week for a ridiculous
trial and while I was gone uh my wife
didn't tell me this until later the may
had sort of incited so much hatred
against us had told people that we
scream at Muslims we yell at Muslims we
tell Muslims they cannot come to our
country unless they convert to
Christianity I've never said such a
thing and to all the Muslims of the
world you Muslim women there who are
being oppressed if you can get to a
country like the United States where you
can have freedom you do it
girl and so I I've never said that in my
life and that's what the mayor is
telling people that we that we do and we
are getting death threats from people
saying they're going to kill us for what
we do not based on anything we actually
do based on what the mayor is saying we
do and then on top of all of that when
people requested the police reports
people are putting in requests so they
could read what actually happened
because they're getting conflict
conflicting reports when they actually
are sending out the police reports they
blotted out everyone's home address
information except mine they left it
right there I was the one who made the V
made the video against the uh the uh
head of the police department and so
they they incite people until they want
to kill us and then they give them
basically a road map to my house and I'm
away in Dearborn and my wife is scared
and she actually has to sit down with my
two oldest Sons who are healthy and tell
them if you hear someone come into this
house who is hurting
me I want you to hide and don't come
out and no matter how bad you hear me
scream just hide because I'm more
worried about
you and that is a conversation that
should never happen in the United States
of America
there there are places where that
conversation needs to take place that
conversation has to take place in
Pakistan and Sudan and Egypt and Iraq
that conversation has to take place it
should never happen here and yet now it
has to and I'll just be honest I live in
the Bronx it's not known for being the
best area of the world I feel safer
walking down the street in the Bronx in
the middle of the night than I do
walking down the street of Dearborn in
broad daylight not because I'm worried
about Muslims attacking me because I
have no confidence in the police here in
the legal system in your courts in your
judges I view them was all corrupt and
I've seen it firsthand and
so uh I feel helpless walking down the
street and I'll say uh I am glad that
there are lawyers in this country who
are willing to take this on because if
they weren't here uh where else would I
turn and you're about to hear from one
of them God bless you all
[Applause]
speaking of
lawyers um I'm honored to bring to you
today um a warrior in the litigation
Jihad in lawfare we we know that our
court systems are being used to impose
the Sharia we know that our court
systems are being used to impose the
blasphemy laws under the Sharia um
restriction of freedom of speech under
the guise of hate speech um I have been
represented by I believe two of the
foremost lawyers in the world in
combating and fighting the Sharia uh
Robert Muse and David yui uh they
represented me in the $10 million
lawsuit filed against Me by rifa Barry's
parents that threatened her when she had
left Islam uh because I heard his
feelings I heard his feelings two years
okay and hundreds of thousands of
dollars This Is How They silence people
This Is How They bankrupt people and
they represent me pro bono uh Robert
Muse represented me along with David
Yami against the city of Dearborn when
they were running ads prosing for Islam
come to Islam why Islam and I ran ads uh
leaving Islam is your family threatening
you is there death threat on your head
and they wouldn't run them and we sued
and Robert and David
won of course the ads didn't run because
they filed an emergency motion as if the
judge was going to reverse herself the
same week but I have to tell you that
the week that Those ads were supposed to
go up in Dearborn it was the week that
Jessica moad was honor murdered uh
they're representing me in New New York
City you know New York City subway
system is running anti-israel ads to end
USA to Israel well we submitted our
pro-israel ad that said in any war
between the Civilized man and the Savage
you side with the Civilized man support
Israel defeat
Jihad Those ads were rejected because
Savages hurt their
feelings yeah but these are serious
cases and I applaud Robert Muse and I
applaud David Yu Shi and the work that
they're doing for American law for
American courts the foreign law
prohibition that if I understand is here
in Michigan it's far it's far it's um HB
4769 and
sb71 you got to get behind this ladies
and gentlemen you've got to get behind
this I mean take an active role and by
the way very very briefly when they tell
you that oh we're not going to be able
to get married and we're not going to be
able to again it's it's deception um
unlike Jewish law there is no compulsion
in Jewish law there is no compulsion in
Christian law Jewish law is for Jews
canon law is for you know cath Catholics
for Christians uh but the Sharia is a
comprehensive legal system that aor
asserts authority over non-muslims it is
different and uh frankly we need this we
need these laws and there should be
absolutely no reason why anyone would
oppose you know the fundamental
Constitution Liberties that are you know
are unalienable rights so I'd like to
bring up Robert Muse so he can better
inform you of the fight on the legal
front because it's critical thank you so
much well thank you all for coming it's
a uh what a terrific turnout for a
Sunday afternoon that's a great I think
Testament to the uh incredible work that
Pam and Robert are doing in this area
you know I I served uh 13 years on
active duty in the Marine Corps and uh
it was my
uh and and I think it's important to
give you a little bit about of my
background you know when as a marine
officer you take an oath to support and
defend the Constitution United States
against all enemies foreign and domestic
I was an infantry officer I served in
the first Persian Gulf War and it became
pretty clear to me uh that we have
perhaps more demestic enemies to our
constitution than we did on foreign
enemies so I decided to go to law school
I went to Notre Dame I got my law degree
and I've been now fighting this these
battles for our for our constitution in
the courtrooms for the last 12
years for good or
ill for good or ill this battle for
America is occurring in the courtrooms
I'm going to cover some of that uh here
today during my presentation uh Pam
mentioned my colleague David yurami
David and I have been doing cases
together for four years some of the more
complicated complex cases in this battle
space fighting Sharia and we decided
this past January to join forces and
launch the American Freedom Law Center
and and to enter into this battle space
and to bring in expertise that I don't
think exists anywhere else and we've had
some some incredible success uh during
our our short time and over the years
that he and I have been working together
and I want to cover some of those cases
with you here today because unless you
hear these facts you'll think that it
never took place here in America but I
can guarantee you that we have domestic
enemies to our Constitution and those
battles are raging every single day what
I want to talk about today it describes
as civilization Jihad a threat to life
and
Liberty CU in Civilization Jihad under
Sharia we don't have a rep there's no
Republican form of government there's no
freedom of speech there's no free
exercise of religion there's no due
process there's no equal
protection in fact as we've been hearing
women are chatt under
Sharia you know I'm a I'm a father of 12
children as I like to say uh all of them
are boys except for 10
so blessed are you among women in my
house and when women uh cheated treated
like chatt that affects me in a very
personal
way you know I'm I'm proud to say even
though we've launched in uh in January
already this uh left-wing British uh
organization they did a a an
International report and they've already
identified the American Freedom Law
Center highlighting it as one of the top
us-based organizations that camp against
civilization Jihad you're damn
straight and they also identified my
colleague David yurami is as has one of
the top 12 uh threats to the
civilization Jihad and they said he's
arguably done more than anyone to fight
civilization Jihad you know the New York
Times this past summer did a full page
story on him front page above the fold I
described him as the man uh The Man
Behind the anti-sharia movement and he
is and I'm very proud to have him as my
colleague
League no this civilization Jihad it
certainly has a kinetic oppon kinetic
component as we saw on September 11th
you know it's it's amazing to me when I
when I talk to so many groups and they
say well what's the concern you know
there the threat's over right didn't we
just hear from our Administration that
there's no longer a you know war and
Terror I mean what does it take you know
these Sharia adherence to fly planes
into our buildings and kill 3,000
innocent Americans before America wake
up but there's another another form
stealth Jihad using the term that Robert
Spencer has uh has coined that is as
equally as pernicious as equally as
harmful and it's occurring and I see it
more so in the in the courtrooms and in
the cases that I'm dealing with and I'm
going to run through some of these but I
want to cover this thing one real quick
a study on us mosques this was a study
that was that was co-authored by my
colleague David yurami it was published
in perhaps one of the most reputable
terrorism peer review journals
perspective Ives on terrorism and they
did a study of us
mosques and this is what the conclusion
was 80% of us Moss provide their
worshippers with Jihad style literature
promoting the use of violence against
non-believers this is a legitimate
peer-reviewed study this threat to our
freedoms is a real
threat it
exists and when I use the term
civilization
Jihad it's not even my term that's their
term that's the term that was coined by
the Muslim Brotherhood this is what they
said in the explanatory
memorandum on the general strategic goal
for the group this document that is
quoted here was actually submitted as
evidence by the Department of Justice in
the largest terrorism financing trial
that's ever been held in the United
States the Holy Land uh financing the
Holy Land uh Foundation trial and this
is what this document says the process
of settlement is a civilization Jihadi
process the Muslim Brotherhood must
understand their work in America is a
kind of grand Jihad and eliminating and
destroying the western civilization from
within and sabotaging its miserable
house by their hands and the hands of
the Believers so that it is eliminated
and God's religion is made Victorious
over all other
religions those are their words and as a
footnote one of the unindicted
co-conspirators in this trial was care
and when care filed a motion to get
their name removed from the pleadings
the motion was denied through every
level of the courts because it was
sufficient evidence presented at trial
that they should have been named as an
unindicted co-conspirator now why they
weren't indicted co-conspirators we'll
have to leave that question you have to
ask that question to the Department of
Justice Civilization Jihad is their
words it's not something that Robert
Spencer wrote in a book or Pam gella put
on her blog this is what the Muslim
Brotherhood is
saying we all know what our apologist
and chief has been saying and what he
said in
2009 he wants to hide the fact that we
have a real threat it's threatening us
today is threatening us both through
violent Jihad and through more
stealthier forms stealth Jihad or
civilization
Jihad let me tell you about some of the
cases the case that David wood was
telling you about I had the uh the
privilege of being the attorney that
represented him in that in that first
criminal
trial David went to the Arab festival
with three other Christian missionaries
to peacefully preach the gospel on the
city
streets and has he
indicated they went there in peace and
they left in handcuffs they spent a
night in
jail
thankfully thankfully they had videotape
and video cameras where they could
capture what actually took place and I'm
going to show you a four minute clip of
the of live video of what transpired on
that night during the Arab Festival in
2010 can I can I eat this Pho Yeah
question what's up what what what's the
problem I have no problem is that why I
I have no problem with Muslims why you
making videos why you trying to make us
look I'm not trying to make you look the
man on the right the
red when we made the video last year we
made it explicitly clear that it was the
security we had an issue with not
everyone at the festival security then
we put up a video afterwards saying and
we want to make this perfectly clear we
don't have any issue with the people
there we have no issue with the people
at Boots we only have issues with people
at security so I I got no issue with you
guys at all no but you didn't say that
in the videos I was just saying the
Islamic people as the community are just
all dead and all ask my mom is Muslim my
dad is Muslim my sister is Muslim all my
cousins are Muslim I love Muslim I got
no problem with the Muslim
Community it was a security guards here
that made
video so you came here looking for
trouble with the security guards w why
you say making all these videos that's a
good question we came here yesterday or
last year and we saw a pamphlet that we
had a question about so we went to the
booth who gave us the pamphlet and we
said hey can we ask you a question about
this and they they said they said yeah
they said they said yeah you can ask
question I don't understand I didn't see
you at like the Spirit Festival why here
another year in a row I just happened to
be here last year my first why you here
want to see if it's going better this
year we wanted to see if it's better
this year than it was last year are you
sure about that I'm pretty sure it's all
the way I think for more trouble we're
not looking for trouble we want to see
things are better and generally things
have been better security hasn't been
hitting US security hasn't been
assaulting us so things are better I'm
glad about that and we're talking right
now no one's stopping us from talking so
I'm glad about these things this is the
very reason I'm here to make sure you
and I can talk so you're here to preach
I would like to preach we haven't even
gotten to that point yet preach to me
then preach to you I would love to
preach to you why is Christianity better
than Islam because Jesus Christ did not
claim to be just a prophet he said he
was here to receive worship he did
receive worship he he forgave people's
sins he miraculously healed people he
died on the cross and rose from the dead
these truths have changed my life have
absolutely changed my life and and I
find it so important to let people know
about these things that I will tell
anyone and everyone who listen so I'm
glad you asked the question as if Allah
isn't like that either why is there more
one Bible why is Allah what makes Jesus
better than Allah Who who okay I got a
bunch of you guys who are asking
questions a question for you so did like
four of these guys I want I want a man a
man a human Jesus decided God what when
was Jesus decided as a God that's an
excellent question 325 years after the
Roman Cil declared him as God no people
are worshiping Jesus as God less than a
decade after his death that's not how
could Jesus be a God if he came like any
of us came out out of a woman he came
like any other man comes out of a woman
yeah so in the Old Testament we see a
prophecy saying that a child will be
born to you and he will be the Mighty
God so in the Old Testament it actually
says the Mighty God will be born has a
child to you and in actuality it can't
just be like a half God it actually says
the Everlasting father avad will be born
to you so this is this is a prophecy we
knew what happen right but how does God
die you said after his death he was be
God that's an excellent question what we
find in the New Testament is that in
order in order for for God to take our
sins away from us he can't just wave
them away uh if God were just to wave
away sins he wouldn't be a just God so
he takes our sins upon himself he says
all right I can't just wave these sins
away that wouldn't make me a just God
I'm going to pay those sins for you
that's how much he loves us and so he
comes into the world as a man and he
takes our sins for us he does it all
voluntarily he doesn't have to do any of
this have you met Jesus yourself say
again
not these are great questions guys I'm
loving this anyone else have a question
yeah uh where where in the Bible says
can you find in the Bible where it says
uh when Jesus says I am God worship me
well in the
when people I'll give you $100 in any
Bible there's 80 of them if you find
me there's 80 Bibles but there's only
one let
me
ex
micone are you legally allowed to take
this the mic are you legally allowed to
go mic
[Music]
that microphone that Nabil kesi had
didn't amplify sound it was simply for
the video recorder so that conversation
was normal voice conversation on a on a
city street that is quintessential First
Amendment protected activity I mean in
fact that was about as peaceful as as
one of the witnesses testified during
the trial it was almost like a classroom
session nibel was taking peaceful
questions from these Muslims who had
very good qu very good questions and he
had very good answers
and what was his crime breach of
Peace again I had the privilege of
representing all four in the criminal
trial in Dearborn and after a weak trial
that video is what I showed in my
closing argument and after I showed that
video I turned to the jury and I said
did what you just witnessed there what
you just saw did that happen in a city
street in the United States of
America thankfully they were all
acquitted
and David Yami and I we turned around we
drafted a 96 page civil rights lawsuit
we sued the mayor we sued the city of
deborn we sued 17 police officers we
sued the chief of police and we sued two
ARA Festival
workers and that litigation is ongoing I
like our
chances here's a case many of you may
not know that much about in fact this is
a case that where David and I started
working together back in
2008 how many of you out here realize
that you are the primary shareholder of
AIG the federal government owns 92
excuse yes the federal government owns
92% of AIG through taxpayer dollars AIG
also happens to be the world leader in
Sharia compliant
financing and I'll tell you a little bit
about Sharia compliant financing but
first with AIG when they when things are
going arai in the economic uh in our
economy back in 2008 the feds gave AIG
$85 billion in
loans shortly after that we passed the
emergency economic stabilization act a
congressional funding statute where we
then gave him $40 billion which replaced
some of that 85 billion and then that
following April we gave him another 30
billion the first 40 billion came in
November around December AIG announced
to the to its shareholders through a
press release from its New York office
that it was now uh opening up its Sharia
compliant businesses in the United
States at the same time the Department
of Justice was having an Islamic Finance
101 seminar for all its policy holders
back in Washington DC louing all the
benefits of sharia compliant financing
under Sharia compliant financing they
can only invest in things that are are
Sharia adherent that promote Islam in
fact AIG meaning you the federal
taxpayers hires a Sharia advisory aboard
which is made up of these imams who make
determinations of how the money should
be uh should be invested
a certain percentage of that ve
investment the profits has to come off
as a zakat a religious tax and those
religious tax can only go to fund
pro-islamic uh charitable organizations
it has to be purified organizations such
as the Holy Land Foundation many of
these organizations promote Hezbollah
and Hamas so you as Federal taxpayers
have given 70 billion dollar in tax
money to prop up and to own AIG and now
you have the sovereign engaged in not
only a religious practice which violates
The Establishment Clause but a religious
practice that has National Security
concerns over a year worth of litigation
and Discovery in the first once we filed
this lawsuit Department of Justice
immediately filed a motion
dismiss and we defeated that in fact the
judge's ruling was
phenomenal was a very courageous ruling
so we had a year to conduct Discovery
and to prove our case and we did in fact
we showed at a minimum $153 million of
federal tax money going directly to
those
businesses surprisingly the federal
judge who ruled not favor the first time
around it was almost like a different
judge had written the opinion he
actually said in his opinion 153 million
out of 70 billion well that's di
Minimus di Minimus you imagine $153
million going to a Catholic
school I just argued this case before
the US court of appeals for the six
circuit last Friday we drew a fairly hos
judge in fact one of the uh one of the
judges said well isn't just this is just
like a a public school uh serving fish
on Fridays for the Catholics there's
nothing like
that in fact the the Department of
Justice attorney who argued against me
the other side kept referring it to as
Sharia
law well we got about a year before a
decision will come down in that case and
I can tell you one thing after deposing
some of the top level treasury officials
who are responsible for this ENT entire
bail out of AIG the federal government
has no clue where their money went no
clue and one of the problems here is AIG
uses what's called Consolidated
financing meaning all the money goes
into one pool and it's all co-mingled
and yet there's no restrictions on any
of your taxpayer money going to pay the
salaries of these imams who by the way
some of them are pretty bad actors one
of them his uh his dad is is uh is
fairly notorious as being someone who's
called for for a violent Jihad against
the West well he's on the taxpayers
payroll working for AIG among these
other
imams I guarantee you that zakat money
is not going to go to the American
Freedom Law Center and help support any
of the work that David Ur and shami and
I are
doing but you as taxpayers now own 92%
of AIG and you're funding all this with
your money $70 billion
worth here's a case that really bothers
me personally Jesse nto he was a
marine uh a marine did two combat tours
in Vietnam a retired Marine Gunnery
Sergeant he retired uh Sometime Late in
in 1980 he then began working at Marine
Corps Base Camp Jun in North Carolina as
a civilian employee I did two two tours
uh with Camp Jun spent six years of my
life living down there gto's oldest son
happened to be on the USS coold as a
sailor he was one of the one of the
sailors that was killed during the
terrorist bombing of the the USS
coal obviously as a a father he grieved
over the loss of his
son one of the ways that he expressed
and
mourned if you look at his license plate
as official North Carolina license plate
is USS
Cole he had those decals we died they
rejoiced No Quarter for Islamic
terrorists
Marine Corp base camp Lun banned his
vehicle from coming on the base because
of those decals they had gotten a
complaint the Marine Corps installation
banned them they told the gun you either
remove those decals or you scrape off
your base
decal which is what allows him to go on
the military installations he said sir
I'm not going to remove those
decals so he went out there with the
hand scraper and he scraped off the
decals and they issued an order to him
that he wasn't allow to bring that
vehicle on any military or federal
installation so he couldn't bring his
vehicle back on base where he worked
where he was a retired Marine had access
to all the uh the health care and
everything
else he couldn't go visit his son's
grave marker at Arlington National
Cemetery in that
vehicle he couldn't go to down to
Virginia to the the Naval Base where the
coal Memorial is because of those decals
follow the federal civil light civil
rights lawsuit on behalf of gunto and
the US District Court for the eastern
district of North Carolina and the judge
ruled in our
favor he ordered the uh the base to
allow him back on the vehicle I got to
tell you that was one of the happiest
calls I ever made to to gunto is when I
when I got the word when he got the
electronic notice that the judge ruled
against the uh the camp leun held it it
was Viewpoint discrimination when I
called gunny I could I could tell he was
uh he was teared up and he was crying on
the other end of the phone this is a a
combat Marine it meant so much to him
that picture there is him going back on
base with this vehicle I said gny get
your vehicle bring it in front of the
camp Jun sign take some pictures and
send it to me and he
did here's one of the cases uh Pam gella
Robert Spencer and afdi the American
Freedom Defense Initiative uh some of
our David and my favorite client because
as you know Pam she's always soft spoken
and never want to want to cause any
[Laughter]
controversy love representing Pam this
is she mentioned this one already she
was she wanted to run this advertisement
on the Detroit
buses and they told her she couldn't
they wouldn't give her a reason why they
just told her she couldn't it was okay
though for them to run this
advertisement don't believe in God so
the atheist advertisement is is okay but
the one addressing Islam is not
okay and in fact even this atheist
advertisement was vandalized they had
vehicles that were being that were being
literally harmed physically damaged and
yet they just kept putting it back up
and they had no problem with
it well our federal judge here in
Detroit ruled in our favor once again
told
them told them they had to put the ads
up the uh the Detroit uh bus agency has
still refused to do that and they've
appealed up the cases out pending before
the US court of appeals for the six
circuit but we we like our chances right
now we have an injunction that the judge
won't enforce but we still won and I I
fully expect to win on appeal in the in
the six
circuit same thing happened in in the uh
afdi versus MTA in New York although
there was a couple of other Frolic and
detours in between down in Miami and and
one other stop in New York where uh just
the threat of suing them where they
backed down they allowed the ads to run
but here the afdi excuse me the Mt dug
in their heels this was the
advertisement pan wanted to run as she
indicated the MTA accepted these
anti-israel advertisements one from a
Palestinian Group which essentially said
look if you're on the side of Palestine
and this battle this Palestinian Israeli
conflict then you're on the side of
justice and you're on the side of Peace
So if you're on the side of Justice
you're on the side of Peace what's on
the other side right it must be inj
unjust it must be violent well when Pam
wanted to run this
advertisement the MTA told him that it
was prohibited because it was demeaning
speech apparently it's demeaning to call
those who engage in violent Jihad
against innocent Israelis Savages and
obviously that line is from an Ann Ran's
book as well Atlas shrugs well David and
I we had a 4-Hour Hearing in a federal
court in downtown Manhattan on uh on
April 3rd and uh after that hearing I'm
I'm pretty convinced even though we had
a pretty hardcore liberal judge he's
going to rule in our favor in fact when
you have a judge at the end uh turn to
your opposing councel and say how much
time do you think you're going to need
to appeal my
ruling you have a good idea where you're
going to
stand you know as mentioned American
laws for American courts that model
legislation was drafted by my colleague
David yurami and anytime this is brought
up in fact it's been passed in three
states and it's pending in in dozens of
uh dozens of other
states and anytime that American laws
for American courts shows up in the
media or it shows up in in any of these
legislative Halls immediately you have
care and the other groups going out
there claiming that it's you know
islamophobia it's a it's attack on Islam
and nothing can be further and let me
take give you a little bit of of facts
because I know the uh care and these
other organizations don't like to deal
with facts American laws for American
courts was was modeled off of federal
legislation which was re recently passed
there was this Phenom going on called
Lial uh Lial torist ISM where in foreign
countries they certainly don't many you
know most countries don't have the First
Amendment protections like we have so
when people write books like Robert
Spencer or or Pam Geller and that are
expressing opinions that people don't
like in some of these foreign countries
they get sued they get sued for liable
and they get sued for defamation and
what was happening is they would take
these foreign
judgments bring them into US courts and
enforce them under these comedy
principles not comedy
comme and so the federal government
finally woke up and they passed
legislation saying that if any foreign
law or foreign judgment if it was going
to be enforced in our courts would
violate our fundamental right to freedom
of speech as protected by the First
Amendment it's null and void and it
cannot be
used what David yurami has done is
essentially take that model legislation
and expand it not so that it it's just
the first amendment but if you have a
foreign law or a foreign judgment that
wants to be enforced in our state courts
that not only violates our First
Amendment right to freedom of speech but
violates our right to free exercise of
religion that violates equal protection
that violates due process it can't be
enforced that is all the law does it
doesn't even mention Sharia but as an
one example in New Jersey JY there was a
a wife I believe was trying to get a
temporary restraining order from a
husband who was brutally treating her
very brutally I don't even want to go
into the details of what it was when he
went to the trial court level he his
argument to the judge was look I'm a
Muslim this is part of my religion this
is part of sharia my wife is my property
and the judge ruled in his
favor thankfully the case was appealed
to the appella court and it was
reversed the center for security policy
whom we work with very closely Frank
Gaffney some of you probably know about
the the tremendous work that they
they're doing they have a whole website
with all the cases they did a survey of
how these the pernicious influence of
foreign laws is having an effect on our
on our Constitution and our laws and all
the American laws from American courts
does is what it says is that here in the
United States American law applies not
Sharia not any other foreign law but
American laws in the primary law the
supreme law of our land is the United
States Constitution
[Applause]
as you can see and and I'm I'm hope I've
I've been able to convey to you today
that this threat this civilization
Jihad is a real threat it's a real
threat not only to our physical safety
as we saw in 9911 but also to our way of
life to our constitutional
freedoms I'm very proud to be part of
these these seminars that Pam and Robert
have been putting on because I think
they've done more than any two people
that I've seen to inform Americans about
this
threat and and just to wrap it up I'd
like to point out the center for
security policy and and Frank Gaffney
has put put together this this education
series on the Muslim Brotherhood and
it's a video series that's available to
you online you can go to our website and
you can see the first uh increment of
that but it's it's critically important
that we become aware of what these
threats are and I applaud you as well
for spending your Sunday afternoon to
listen to us hopefully become more
better educated about these issues and
to pass it on thank you again for your
time thank you Robert let let me just
ask you a
question this is nothing new right
you've heard about all these stories
that uh that Robert Muse and David wood
have told you've seen them on ABC and
NBC and CBS
right you've seen them on Fox all over
the place
right what a funny thing isn't that odd
and actually it's not odd at all
obviously we all know that in the United
States right now the mainstream media
for whatever reason is completely
complicit with the Sharia initiatives
that are trying to advance Islamic law
and to assert the principle that
wherever Islamic law and American law
conflict it's American law that has to
give way in Islamic law it is forbidden
for non-muslims to prosze among Muslims
it's not forbidden in the United States
for Christians to preach Christianity so
what Dearborn was doing to David wood
and nail kesi and the others was
enforcing Islamic law upon them now this
should have been front page Banner
headlines in the New York Times and the
Detroit Free Press and everywhere else
this should have been first lead story
all week on all the top news channels
because this is a story about our
fundamental rights and instead if they
reported at all if it if it got into the
Free Press at all you can be sure it was
about
islamophobia and it was about hate
speech well you saw Nabil you saw the
video he wasn't preaching hate and
neither are we we are preaching the
defense of our rights we are preaching
freedom and equality of Rights for all
people
there's nothing hateful about saying we
want everybody to be subject to the same
law and the same
responsibilities and everyone have the
same rights under the law oh what how
hateful but
anyway the thing is the media we know is
nowhere the media as Pamela has dubbed
it is the en media is on the other side
as a matter of fact we have to leave the
country to find anyone with a prominent
Voice who has the courage to speak about
these things honestly and I'm very happy
to say he's with us here now y Michael
Corin is the host of a television show
on the excellent sun TV network in
Canada he is one of the very few people
in the media who has the courage to take
on these issues to discuss them fully
and honestly without the can't without
the aisc without the denial and without
the propaganda that the mainstream media
steadily subjects us to when it comes to
issues of how Islamic law is threatening
our freedoms and so it is with great
pleasure and honor I introduce to you
Michael
Corin thank
you thank you that was very nice bit
more if you like I'm fine with that
thank you for uh inviting me to your
lovely little
country as an Englishman I've always
wanted to say that to Americans and as a
Canadian I
can I just explain a little bit about my
background because now by the way I have
to establish that you can understand me
because I speak English
properly and you're American so uh I'm
from England originally I've been in
Canada half my life I was a journalist
in the UK and uh the only reason I ended
up in Canada is because golly back in
1986 I was at the University of Tana as
they call it I was invited over to give
a lecture and uh at the party boring
conference but at a party at the end of
the conference this this very beautiful
woman came up to me and she she must
have been drunk she said she said you're
amazing you're amazing and thinking this
may never happen again I married
her and I was quite right because it
hasn't happened ever again so
that is how I I I got to can but you
know I grew up in Britain in a little
town called ilford which is where London
and Essex meet there's nothing ilford
ilford Anonymous but I grew up I went to
the local state school it was very nice
univ of Britain we had educ free
Education and healthc Care and the Queen
and Dentistry no not the
last it was a lovely way to grow up with
the great benefits of of of Britain in
in the 1960s and and 1970s there was
young man who grew up uh three streets
away from me uh but he my father drove a
cab drove a cab those black cabs in
England we weren't particularly wealthy
uh he he did have money this young man
who grew up just three streets away from
me so he went to the local private
school his parents could afford
that he had the best of everything
Britain could give a as as North America
gives tolerance and pluralism and
respect no I'm serious about that no I'm
not this is not a joke uh we are are the
postchristian world the world
established on Christianity is a light
unto the rest of the universe Britain
North America Australia New
Zealand Europe what do these all have in
common pragmatism liberalism no no
Christianity but anyway he he grew up
with all the benefits of the United
Kingdom he went on after his private
education to be a member of a gang who
kidnapped Danny Pearl and cut his head
off
not of course before they had made him
confess and admit to being a
Jew and then they held his severed head
up to the camera as a warning to
others I'm sure the oppression and the
Injustice and the poverty that young man
had grown up in turned him into a
murderer not his
religion
anyway let me talk to you a little about
what goes on in Canada now I feel almost
embarrassed to be here what I've heard
here I mean what can I say I thought I
knew about what Islamic radicalism
Sharia law the strict interpretation of
the Muslim faith led to but what I what
I've heard here I thought Canada was in
bad shape what happened especially in
that in that discussion of the Christian
Gospel is beyond belief a young woman I
don't if she's in the room now a young
woman from the Arab American uh news
station said to me outside and she was
very nervous and I felt for her she she
was shaking she said do you think
Dearborn is the right place for this
conference I said I'm not really sure
let me change that answer yes it is yes
it is the right place for this
conference good Lord good Lord people
have died for the freedom we've taken
for granted for so long and that should
happen in in a city it just it just I'm
baffled I'm baffled but it it it's not
confined of course to this country let
me tell you about a man called Mark
Harding Mark Harding is a criminal Mark
Harding is a criminal he can't come to
your country he can't cross the border
because he's been convicted of a crime
now if you met Mark Harding if you met
him he's a big S of teddy bear of a guy
rather simple fellow really I don't say
that in a pejorative way he's he's a
lovely man but I think he would ADM met
a pretty basic fellow in many ways
doesn't claim to be a great thinker a
deep intellectual thank the Lord he's
just a lovely fellow but he is also a
criminal and he cannot travel across the
border what did he do well some years
ago some years ago he decided that he
would hand out some leaflets close to a
Muslim School outlining the way
Christians and other minorities are
treated in the Islamic world this is not
a point of debate it's not a fantasy
it's not a myth as we speak as I speak
to you now another Christian is being
beaten raped murdered for being a
Christian in the Islamic
world it's a fact it's an open wound
festering and he handed out these belief
that there was no foul language no
pornography no naked women no insults
just listing some of the awful things
that have been done to
Christians in the Islamic Heartland and
the Islamic
Homeland he was charged with a hate
crime he is so far the only man in
Ontario to be convicted of a hate crime
he was found guilty of having an
opinion his sentence was to perform
community service in the local is
Islamic community center which he said I
will do with great love and pleasure he
said I will happily clean the toilets I
will happily clean the toilets for other
people made in the image of God and they
said no no no no no no you won't you
will sit down and three Muslim leaders
will lecture you about the truth of
Islam and if you object to what they say
if you argue with them about what they
say you will have
broken the sentence regulations and you
will go to
prison in other words a man who dared to
tell the truth truth about the
persecution of Christians in Pakistan
and Sudan and Egypt and Gaza was told
you will now listen to an indoctrination
session about Islam and if you object we
put you in jail with the Thugs and the
rapists and the
murderers he was on my show and he's not
an overly emotional
man he sat there and I said how you
doing now and he
said not bad but and then he broke down
and he said I had a heart ATT
attack the stress I had a heart attack
you
said uh and I take 40 different tablets
a day to keep me alive but I'm okay and
then he recovered his dignity not that
he'd ever lost it and just looked at the
camera that's happening in
Canada let me tell you about a a public
school we have no separation of church
and state as you have here but
effectively we do and we have a a public
education system schools where if you if
you dare to talk about Christianity
believe me you'll be in big trouble
they've just voted to ban Gideon Bibles
from a school system because after if
any child is given a Gideon Bible well
come you know all hell break loose so
that can't be done but in this public
school funded by the public they've
decided that one day a week it's mosque
time and the cafeteria classes disrupted
so the cafeteria is turned into a mosque
where boys and girls are SE separated
and at the very back it's the young
women who are menstruating because they
obviously are filthy and they can't be
anywhere near even the girls who in the
second row so they way at the back all
on Public Funding simultaneously if you
dare to mention Christianity in one of
these schools you'll be sent home with a
very angry note to your
parent you probably heard of Ezra
evant you heard of Ezra evant yes I'd
like to say he was a great man but I I
know him too well no he's a great man
and he also has a show on Sun News and I
I know most of you can't get Sun News in
the United States but please watch on
the various uh blogs and and websites
and on YouTube because we will we won't
hold back until they drag us off
screaming and kicking and boy we will
kick and scream and fight and bite and
pinch and
whatever we'll carry on speaking the
truth Ezra was charged under a blasphemy
law now they didn't call it that because
even they are not quite that stupid Ezra
Ezra is a wonderful guy who uh survives
it seems to me and I work next to him on
a diet of Red Bull and um and Red Bull
he uh he had a small magazine in western
Canada and he decided that unlike
everyone else pretty much in media he
would print the cartoons of Muhammad by
Kurt vestard by the way I've had the
pleasure of interviewing Kurt vestard
and spending time with him Kurt vestard
the Danish cartoonist he's an Anar he's
really a left-wing Anarchist he's made
more fun of Christianity over the years
than he ever did of Islam of course and
the cartoon he drew of Muhammad was
really quite innocuous but even if it
wasn't tough tough luck if it wasn't
what's the cartoon meant to be it's
meant to be a cartoon okay so the media
of course would not print the cartoon
the great the great New York Times we
know about the great New York Times I'm
we're not going to run the cartoon
because we feel we have the literal
ability to depict the cartoon in our
words terrific but then when you wrote
about when you wrote about a picture of
the Virgin Mary covered in excrement
that Point suddenly you couldn't
describe it in words and you had to run
the picture what happened to their
journalistic ability so the cowards at
the New York Times who were too
physically frightened to run the cartoon
and this happened everywhere we have a
So-Cal conservative newspaper that was
about to run the cartoon in Canada they
took a security costing and they
concluded it wasn't worth the money it
would have cost too much money to make
the building safe we now decide morality
and journalistic integrity on how much
it'll cost to keep your staff safe from
violence and threats but Ezra said nope
I'm going to run the cartoon he ran the
cartoon got in real trouble and then he
and then it got even worse he went on
radio in Calgary Alberta to argue with a
local Islamic leader both on radio
together and they argued about
Islam end of the interview end of the
session the Islamic leader went to the
police and said I want this man charged
he said nasty things about Islam and the
police said uh I'm afraid we don't do
this in
Canada uh yet I'm afraid we don't do
that in Canada so he went to the local
Human Rights Commission and he and I've
seen it he scribbled on a piece of paper
just scribbled on a piece of paper and
the Human Rights Commission said well
take that case and they prosecuted Ezra
and they wouldn't let it go and it went
on for years and cost huge amounts of
money the man who brought the
prosecution never had to even turn up
for any session and for him Ezra was
given no legal representation but being
Ezra and surviving on Red Bull and Red
Bull he said I'm not going to give in
and he fought the case and he fought the
case and he had a camera set up and he
sat there with this human rights
commissioner and he said to her you are
a thug your employers are thugs you're a
bully you're a fascist and I'm not going
to back down and God bless him for that
and he won and he
won
so so we are fighting back but let me
talk about the specific specific oh I I
have to say this do you get little
mosque on the Prairie in the US do you
get that show you
do because it's made by something called
the CBC men used to run away to C now
they run away to the CBC the CBC is our
publicly funded broadcaster that seems
intent on doing all it can to destroy
Christianity and and decency and
Civility and we the director where the
anti- CBC we're the alternative you know
it's like if you're terribly ill you
take us you get better
but the CBC has given us an alleged
comedy show it's not funny called little
mosque on the Prairie where the the Imam
is this very good-looking hip
guy and all the Muslims are fun and
lovable the clever ones are the white
ones the less clever ones are the black
ones little bit of implicit racism in
there you know but the really stupid
people are the Christians who just go
around either being ignorant or bigoted
and they've sold this show all over the
world it's a very typical mosque in can
Canada yeah so we have that to fight
I've yet to see the episode where where
the youngest daughter is
slaughtered and where another wife is
brought in because the first wife's
getting a bit too unattractive and can't
give the the man a child I've never seen
the the episode where they sponsor
International terrorism but I I'm I'm I
am assured I'm guaranteed that in the uh
the Blu-ray DVD Edition it's on the
special features
let
me let me tell you
about about
how white liberal guilt has terrible
consequences this is made profoundly
clear in Canada forgive me if I read
this during the three-month trial of
Muhammad shafia his wife tuba yaha and
their son hammad they were convicted
thank God thank God they were convicted
the first degree murder of Zab who was
19 Sahar 17 and giti shafia who was
13 and 50-year-old Rona Amir the three
teens were Muhammad chafi and Tu yaha's
daughters Hamed sisters Runa was
Muhammad shafi's first wife the four
women had been drowned in their car in
June
2009 listen to this The Killers had
chosen the canal in Kingston Kingston a
University Town halfway between Toronto
and Montreal because they assumed that
the local police would be less
sophisticated and able than those in a
larger City this is how deep and planned
the evil is they' also researched murder
techniques on the internet and planned
the honor killing the Islamic honor
killing long in
advance now the case really shook the
country
but it was only the most recent of a
dozen murders in the last 12 years in
Canada only has 32 3 3 million people
the most recent of a dozen murders in
the last 12 years that's one a year
almost all involving Muslim Patriarchs
aided by sons cousins and wives how
could they killing young girls who
wanted to be horribly Western by wearing
nice clothes dating nice boys doing nice
things Often by the way dating Muslim
boys what they were dating Muslim boys
it's not the right boys that the these
these killers wanted in the shafir
episode the three daughters had refused
to wear the burka and one of them had
even dared to wear a bikini good Lord
Rona Amir had been able to give her
husband children so he had taken a
second wife even though polygamy is
illegal in Canada it goes on believe me
there are numerous polygamist weddings
marriages that take place the
authorities know about it and they
refuse to
intervene although not the girl's
biological mother Rona had love them and
tried to protect them and so she had to
die as
well but there's a great Point here
there's a greater Point here with more
long-term consequences in this one
single repugnant case the authorities
this is very important the authorities
be they police politicians social
workers social workers media are
obsessed with appearing to be
Progressive and not and non
nonjudgmental where Islam is concerned
partly out of a fear of being accused of
islamophobia but also because and I
think this has to be said because they
genuinely believe that the white
Christian West has more to learn from
Islam than the country I really believe
this to be true the shafir girls had
pleaded it it it it makes you weak they
had pleaded with their teachers for help
and while some teachers and some
Frontline social workers acknowledged
the situ the situation was potentially
disastrous the concerns evaporated they
just evaporated as soon as they reached
middle management as soon as anyone in
administration whether it was police or
education or social work found out they
said let's Let It Go let's let it go
it's their culture so Muhammad shafir
who had written of his daughters and I
will say the word forgive me May the
devil [__] on their
graves a
father was effectively permitted to
commit mass
murder as soon as it took
place commentators cringingly reluctant
to link the crime in any way with Islam
the every euphemism they could employ
the M moments after the verdict was
announced the lead detective and he did
a good job he did a good policing job
the lead detective in the case told the
police quote domestic violence is a
terrible
thing well it is but this wasn't
domestic violence and we've just had I
mentioned to you little mosque on the
Prairie we've just had the lead actor
from Little mosque on the Prairie who's
married to the the number two at English
language CBC how the circles form
eh who's on a radio ad saying as the man
who plays the good-looking Imam in
little musk on the Prairie domestic
violence is
wrong we know that that's why it's
illegal in the Western World this was an
honor killing it's different we have
never approved of domestic violence you
enshrine it in your legal system in the
Islamic
world it was yet another example of a
psychosis that has as at its epicenter
Pakistan but extends to most parts of
the Islamic Heartland and many in the
Muslim
diaspora look it's a self-evident truth
and not all Muslims behave like this but
it's also a self-evident truth that more
than 90% of people who do behave like
this are Muslim it's like this nonsense
about terrorism oh you say all Muslims
are terrorists no I've never said such a
thing but I do say the vast majority
invariably the bulk of terrorism is
committed by Muslims in the name of
Islam I'm not saying that they are maybe
it will be a basic courtesy for me to
believe
them they're empowered by quranic
teaching by Sharia law
they're not doing something in spite of
their faith when a Christian commits a
crime it's in spite of Christian
teaching when a Jew commits a crime it's
in spite of Jewish teaching I'm sorry
when Muslims commit honor killings it's
not in spite of it's because of Islamic
teaching when when 16-year-old 16year
old AXA pz was murdered in Canada 2007 I
think it
was by her Pakistani father and brother
K Canada yeah we have the version too
our own special version K
Canada told the gallal that quote it's
important not to
generalize there are cases of violence
across all faiths and
cultures yeah we never said otherwise
but actually when it comes to honor
killings almost unheard of outside of
Islam and the small number that have
occurred in Hinduism and Sikhism are is
ated and universally condemned within
those cultures when I see the mass ranks
of Canadian Muslims marching along the
streets of Toronto and Montreal saying
no to honor killings I may think
again it won't happen don't hold your
breath look it's not just about honor
killing the country I'm from Britain we
now have a whole plague
of of rape gangs gangs of young Muslim
men throughout the country one even in
Oxford recently such a a quiet beautiful
place where young women young white
women are groomed raped drugged and
turned into prostitutes over and over
and over again even conservative tblo
like the daily maale will print the
pictures of the men they're all of
Pakistani origin or 99% of them with
their names but they won't say the magic
word Muslim they can't say the word now
if it happens to be a Norwegian mass
murderer who's a Freemason who says in
his Manifesto I have no relationship
with Christ I haven't been to church in
17 years uh I actually support abortion
rights and gay
marriage but you'll call him a Christian
as soon as you can and you'll continue
to call him a Christian as time goes on
even though he's far from being one but
if someone commits an honor killing or
an act of Terror and says I did it in
the name of Islam because I'm a Muslim
you will still find a way to say it's
the fault of the Jews
I don't know what's going to happen in
Canada we have a heroic fight back we
have people like I mentioned EZ relevant
and Mark Stein who you probably know of
here as well but he's one of
ours we have a government a sort of
conservative government that is very
good on this issue and a wonderful
immigration Minister Jason Kenny who is
prepared to say no to extremism we have
a we have a Prime Minister Steven Harper
who was the first person to say no no no
to Hamas long before the Americans got
into it we said no to Hamas as soon as
they won we're not backing you anymore
we're taking all the money away
so so there is great hope but the
problem is among so many people the mass
indifference engineered by media
everyone is the same
relativism fundamentalism is the problem
here not the particular religion well
the next time a fundamentalist Quaker or
a fundamentalist Catholic or a
fundamentalist Unitarian tries to cut my
head off or blow my plane up I'll start
to believe them until then just shut
up it's a real pleasure and honor to be
here and to meet people I mean I've
never met Pam she Pam's been on my show
many times never actually met her now
I've met her Robert I have met before
but other people I've never met before
that the work you're doing really is
extraordinary and I I want to end with
an anecdote and and I don't use this in
any way to be exclusive I have I'm a
Catholic I mean if you're not that's
your problem but I'm a
cathol I'll pray for
you but I won't threaten to cut your
head
off but one of the great influences
Inspirations in my life has been a man
called Thomas Moore he he he's a saint
he was he was Prime Minister of England
he was called Chancellor but he was
Prime Minister of England he was one of
the great public intellectuals brilliant
known throughout the world and he had
everything really and then King Henry
VII decided he wanted to take a
different
wife and that was really the issue it
wasn't actually the Reformation it was
just about marriage and Thomas mo said
you can't do this your majesty you're
already married and anyway they fell out
and mo was arrested he lost everything
he he lost all his money his power his
family weren't allowed to see him he
knew he was going to die and and he was
interrogated he wasn't physically
tortured but he was interrogated night
after night after night and the last
interrogation before he was executed
before they did cut off his head he was
taken from the Tower of London to
Lambeth Palace and and he sat there thin
bearded by this point and in front of
him was the new prime minister Thomas
Cromwell the Duke of norfol the most
powerful Aristocrat in the country the
Archbishop of Canterbury when that
really meant
something and they sat there and they
hared him
more than an
hour and he just wouldn't say anything
just wouldn't say anything and at the
end as they were packing up the dukee of
norfol said to him oh for goodness sake
he said this is pride this is pride he
said because look we're in the majority
look Thomas we're in the majority and
for the first time Thomas Moore his eyes
opened up there was a new Clarity in
them he looked up and he gazed right at
them and he said well he said knowing he
would die in the morning if the Gates of
Heaven if the wind Windows of the
afterlife could open now you would see
that no no no no I'm in the
majority no matter how persecuted and
alone and isolated you may feel when you
leave here and you go back to your homes
remember
remember decency goodness integrity and
morality you we are in the majority
thank you so much Michael
and I wanted to pick up on one thing
that Michael said a few minutes ago he
he referred to the rape gangs in Britain
and it really is astonishing at Jihad
watch I I I cover these things all the
time and there's so many stories I lose
track of these gangs of Muslim men who
kidnapped non-muslim girls and they forc
them into prostitution and a clue to
this
actually two Clues I discovered last
summer when a Kuwaiti actually termed a
feminist legislator a woman uh in the
Kuwaiti Parliament she made a speech
saying that uh the practice of sex
slavery really ought to be revived that
it was perfectly in accord with Islamic
law that the Quran 4:3 says that a man
can have up to four wives as well as
have sexual relations with the captives
that his right hand possesses and that
those are women who are captured who
were the wives of the uh of the
non-muslims who were killed in battle
with the Muslims they can be
legitimately taken and pressed into
sexual slavery she said that she had
checked with the imams about this and
they said this was fully in accord with
Islamic law now while this story was
making the rounds and it was sort of
unbelievable and people were saying no
that can't be true come on or she must
be some kind of nut then an Imam from
Egypt I believe it was uh came out with
completely independently and said
essentially the same thing and because
it's in the Quran that you can have the
captives your right hand possesses this
is something that no muslim can
question even if it's a dead letter in
most parts of the world today it is
something that any Muslim can like these
two Muslim leaders can say well this
really ought to be revived and they can
make a case for it now this is Islamic
law Islamic law allows for slavery it
allows for the capture of infidel women
and their use in this way Reliance of
the traveler the manual of Islamic law
that I referred to before and the Pamela
referred to before actually says that a
woman who's captured in battle her
marriage is immediately en
olded and then she can be pressed into
this kind of slavery this is in Islamic
law Islamic law Sharia allows for this
it allows for Honor killing as I
explained before it allows for the
denial of the freedom of speech that
David would came up
against it allows for the denial of the
freedom of conscience Muhammad the
prophet of Islam he said if anybody
changes his religion kill him and the
Islamic law in all the schools of law
all across the world mandates the death
penalty for apostasy so that this is
something that Noni and others who've
left Islam they have this over their
heads for the rest of their lives and
there's nothing that can amarate it
because even if you find you say oh no
you're you're you're generalizing and
stigmatizing and look I have 25 Muslims
over here who will never kill non and
disapprove of it well it only takes one
over
there and God forbid anything happens to
her or to any other person who exercises
his conscience and decides to follow
what he believes or she believes is true
and leaves Islam but this is Islamic law
now we know that there have been
initiatives in many states to try to
Outlaw Sharia to try to ban Islamic law
and not allow it to be used and we know
that the Hamas linked Muslim Brotherhood
group the Council on American Islamic
relations and others like it dedicated
in their own words and that captured
Muslim Brotherhood document that Robert
quoted to eliminating and destroying
Western Civilization from within and
sabotaging its miserable house they have
fought successfully against these
measures in many states by claiming that
Sharia is not political it's not
supremacist it does not deny any of
these freedoms it's benign religious law
and if you outlaw it you're restricting
Muslims religious
freedom now in reality Sharia is
political it's supremacist it asserts
asserts authority over non-muslims and
it denies them basic rights as well as
denying women basic
rights and so our next speaker is
someone who has been in the
trenches in the fight to raise awareness
about these issues to educate people
about the true nature of sharia and to
show people the implications of what
happens if we admit it into our country
as the founder and head of the Virginia
anti-sharia task force he has been on
the front lines of some of the key
battles battles here again that you'll
never hear about on the news but are
some of the most pivotal battles to
protect our freedoms in America today
and so it is an honor for me to
introduce to you now James laferty of
the Virginia anti-sharia task force
well it happened again today every time
I appear at one of these conferences
with my friends Pamela and Robert
someone will say to me are you Pamela's
bodyguard it's because I'm a growing boy
and um and I say no Pamela gella
protects me and she protects all of us
I'm from the far off land of
Virginia uh I head and founded the
Virginia anti-sharia task force not by
choice um I have read a lot of the
research done by Nina Shay on the Saudi
madrasas the international Saudi
madrasas only to find that I had one a
couple of blocks from my home uh
operated by the Saudi government on the
title it says Embassy of Saudi
Arabia and um my wife and I went to a
Board of Supervisors meeting in Fairfax
County
Virginia and you can see it on YouTube I
think and uh and we asked why was
Fairfax County Leasing Property to
people who Advocate the killing of
Christians and Jews and we got an awful
reaction from and I have to say it was
bipartisan Republicans and Democrats
came down on us heavily the chairman see
when in Washington when you're a bad
politician you get
promoted and uh and the chairman of the
Board of Supervisors in Fairfax county
is now Congressman jury
Connelly
so he uh he said that U that I had
slandered Islam of course the Board of
Supervisors role is to protect Islam and
uh and he said I had slandered Islam and
he he was very angry
and I said and you sir a traitor's
liar and it went downhill from
[Applause]
there um I have seen and heard many of
the same things about that you've heard
from the other speakers uh the confusion
about Islam uh where a lot of people see
it as uh just another denomination sort
of a group of unitarians who are having
a bad
day um I don't think that at all uh in
our neighborhood and I live in the
wahabi carer I live right off of Route 7
in Virginia Northern Virginia the darl
hedra mosque is there which is the 911
mosque um when I dropped my son off at
school I stopped for coffee in a coffee
shop where the attack on the Pentagon
was planned and I make a point of
sitting at that
table because most of the it is the
crossroads of terrorism Northern
Virginia right now uh those who keep
records of things say that right here in
Dearborn you have the largest Enclave
but false church is the second largest
and I have to tell you we Virginia are
rooting for you guys to keep that
title we fight every day and every night
um I believe that the the jihadists
think that we have people who live in
the county courthouse because every time
they apply for a permit every time they
show up for even the smallest detail a
bunch of our people show up too every
time there is an auction of land of a
large property of land and we know that
they're going to be there we show up for
the auction I try to do a lot of that
myself and I just say if you if you buy
this land here you're going to be seeing
a lot of me and we make sure that that
what we do is legal we're not
threatening in any way but we make sure
that they know that we're going to play
an active role in any of this and that's
what I encourage all of you to do here
um we've been able to stop a lot of this
before it gets to to the point where Mr
Muse and Mr y shami have to get involved
we've been able to beat them at places
like the Planning Commission in Fairfax
County where we just show up and and we
bring some of our friends like Glenn
Beck
um and they're not ready for any of that
they're not ready to be famous we make
sure that their pictures and names are
distributed in Evangelical and friendly
Catholic churches I believe evangelicals
Catholics and Jews are going to save
this
country
um they call us the people of the book
and I know many of you have read that
book and it ends great the ending is
great okay and we think that this we we
know how that book ends so we're
confident about dealing with them but I
would ask you along with all that you've
heard here today and you've heard some
really sad alarming things that you take
heart they can be beaten we can beat
them I mean one of the things I suggest
you do is read saol linsky's rule for
Radicals as a conservative that's a
strange recommendation for me to make
but it is a great guide on Grassroots
organizing and we use many of those same
tactics to fight the very people that
Alinsky was trying to help uh so use
some of that but organize organize
organize and when they have a hearing
any sort of public meeting show up when
they have when you can meet with someone
talk with your the political leaders
tell them how can concerned you are
about this and you're going to watch
them and watch how they vote and just
make sure they know that they're not
getting away with anything look at their
political contributions which is what we
do go through the the Federal Election
Commission reports if it's a federal
official or the local they have some
sort of disclosure they have to do look
at the people who are giving them money
cuz nine times out of 10 that's going to
tell you who's owned by the Saudis or
the jihadist or whatever breed of the
they are and and just pay attention to
that uh we can win you know this is a
country that was founded by Miracles and
it may we may need another one right now
but we can do it and we're counted on to
use our wisdom and our power to fight
these people and I would just encourage
you learn all that you can but at some
point it's okay to stop learning and
start fighting and we need to start the
fight yesterday what's interesting with
Jessica moad um and there are certain
trends that you need to pay attention to
in America is uh Laura recart was the
lead prosecutor in the nor El Malaki
case nor Al Malaki was uh targeted uh by
her father who ran her over and ran over
her uh boyfriend's mother together um
and uh it was the first successful
prosecution in the United States of
America based on honor killing and honor
violence it's a very significant case uh
this prosecutor who knew nothing about
um Islamic teaching knew nothing about
honor killings was she said
that the prosecutor's office became no's
family because no was fighting to get
away from the uh oppressive uh
subjugation and and and Terror in her
household by her father and it was a
successful prosecution on on a killing
uh Laura rehart was enormously
disappointed that it was not a first
degree that it was a second degree
murder um and the of course the utter G
uh on her father's part wanting the
defense wanting the death penalty so
they could say that you were they were
pursuing the death penalty for racist
reasons so he could kill nor Al Malaki
based on Islamic teaching but if you
were to prosecute based on that teaching
then you're a
racist yes now you look at Aura reckart
who said while she was investigating
this case she was shocked at the fear in
the
community that women were afraid to
talk that they never put no's best
friend on the stand because they knew
that her life wouldn't be worth a plug
nickel and after they successfully
prosecuted the nor al-maliki case they
get every day emails from women in
trouble that don't know what to do
Muslim women so let's look at a Laura
recart and support her and you look at a
bill canalo who's a
coward who knew immediately that Jessica
moad was an honor killing who was on
record of course if you go to the
Detroit free free press that article
where he went on and said this was an
honor killing that the father killed her
because she was too westernized that
that article scrubbed it's gone it's not
only scrubbed it's scrubbed from the way
back machine too the internet archives
uh so when you look at this this room
and I will tell you that I'm overwhelmed
and thrilled by this room because you'll
notice there are no politicians here you
know the mayor uh kanur local officials
were all at the were all at the backlash
of phobia that we at the Pro honor
killing um uh rally earlier
today but they're on the wrong side
they're on the wrong side of
righteousness and you have to get behind
politicians that get it you have to get
behind politicians that understand it
what you're witnessing here what we have
here is really the the stages the
various
stages Mr Corin speaks of Canada speaks
of the UK non speaks of the Middle East
stage one stage two stage three stage in
the islamization and my next speaker I I
would like to say I have very very few
Heroes if any um uh but my next speaker
is truly uh my hero um I admire him so
deeply and so enormously uh he is a
giant a giant among men um you know we
hear a lot about Sudan and we hear a lot
about D Dar for and we hear a lot about
George Looney you know out there you
know with Sudan standing outside the
embassy Sudan never speaking of root
cause never speaking about the Jihad
about the Jihad in Dar for the millions
of victims and I really believe that if
not for Simon D we wouldn't know what
was going on there if not for Simon D
under the Bush Administration I don't I
he'll speak to this and what you he can
accomplish under the Obama
Administration there would have been no
referendum
the South voting 99% voting to secede
from the Islamic North after Decades of
Jihadi Wars land Appropriations cultural
Annihilation and and
enslavement he walked Barefoot through
the Senate to get the attention of
senators he walked from New York the UN
to Washington on the freedom walk there
is no one there is no Warrior greater
than the son of kings and slave former
slave Simon D
Simon thank you very much thank you P
thank you Robert thank you for having us
here and most important let's give
applaud to all these speakers here they
done a wonderful
job most important I would like to
thanks all of you by being so patiently
enough and being with us here today even
that knowing that in your heart that you
will not walk out in this room today
happy to see or to to hear from that
that you attend a good conference
because you will walk out being afraid
that you attend the conference which is
bashings and lashing
Islam in my opinions
this kind of
conference it is
not an
anti
religions it is not designed to bash and
lash
Islam in my opinions as a victims under
the Islamic law the Sharia
law this kind of conference is designed
to bring up things that happens Under
the Umbrella of Islam
in which that
nobody especially here in
America have a decently of gut to tell
the truth about what crime being
committed in the name of
Islams this kind of conference in my
opinions it helped people like me the
victims that
happen to be silence because nobody body
want to talk about how they are being
victimized because that person is will
be afraid to be called that you are
anti-islam and you are
Islam this kind of
conference it give victims like me the
voice to speaks on behalf of those
Southern Sudanese Christians infidels
that they call
it a chance to F to speak or what they
cannot speak fors or what is happening
in that part of the
world my fellow human beings and my
fellow
Americans this kind of conference is a
wakeup
call if you don't allow them to be said
then you still living in a dream without
knowing what is coming to you even that
you know what already have come to you
this kind of conference it is to expose
things that being Advocates and
being taughts in the most and I go back
to where I come
from in the part of us in New York when
the Blan
shman was teaching in Brooklyn in the
MOs that telling his fellow followers
Muslims that it is you the one you you
are the lucky ones you who made it here
in America to bring down the
infidels you are the ones who will bring
down American and you are the one who
will build the Moses here in the
US he was telling the truth to his
fellow
Muslims but nobody at that time took
that blind Shake an old man that
seriously that he have a mission or he's
on the missions for God's sakes it was
the same blind she who came
through sudans come to the United States
with the Sudanese documents given by the
Islamic government in [__] to come and
bring down the
infidels or to cut the head of the
infidels how I know it because I was
being called an infidels in that country
it was
OMD who
went and tried to bring
down the World Trade
Center the first
one and he couldn't made it and probably
he
regret that the job would not happen
under his watch so that he will go down
as a
hero this kind of
conference is bringing and waking you up
against because what will come tomorrow
will not Shock you to say that I wish I
would have wake
up yes of
course when an American government and
persecutors put the blind sh behind bar
they went and then went to sleep against
they said the job is finished he's
under behind bar nothing is going to
happen against guess what
my fellow human
being they came and you was watching and
you were sleeping because you are so
naive the World Trade Center was
attack the Pentagon was attack and
American was attack it
was a
Jihad it was not done by the blind sh
because the blind Shake is already
behind but it was done by the people who
never even met the blind Shake
itself that give you the magnitude of
the problem that in hand coming to you
but here
again who want to stand up and say that
no I can i s it then I'm not going to go
to sleep again being you American so
naive always
all you are busy on is to
spend $2 billion a
week to
protect and tomorrow will be an Islamic
government in
Afghanistan that is what you
doing then why should I be talking about
that let me speak of what happened to my
peoples and what happened to me
personally in Sudan
probably you most of you come to know
Sudan about what happened in that four
because the crimes in that for happen on
the Muslim
peoples yes we
went
and tell it as it is and given it the
right name as a genocide of
course I was myself as a victim knowing
that no child should go through what I
went through I was advocating on behalf
of the Muslim because we have to protect
all human right regardless of being
Buddhist or being a Muslim or being a
Christian or being a Jewish all of them
are human
beings
[Applause]
but what you didn't do as Americans and
what you didn't do as the West
you didn't rise up when the crime was
being committed by the Muslims on the
Christians this is the devil
standard and I will if you allowed me to
elaborate or to give you a little bit
why I call it dou standard it was the
same
government in Kum the Islamic government
the government that supported Usama bin
L not supportting him creating Usama bin
L the government brought
Omar ABD here in other word the
government that
behind Bringing Down the World Trade
Centers even that we didn't went after
them in
cartoons I don't know
why if there the one who brought us B
the are one who give the blind shakes to
come to you to attack you and indeed
they manage and we live left him
alone what I want to say here it is the
same government that they slaughter
400,000 Muslims in the
four and the whole world call it by the
right name as a genocide it is
true killing a human being is a murder
killing three people four people it's a
m killing 4 100,000 is a
massacre and now my people Southern
Sudanese were so
angry they could not believe the double
standard that happening
especially to us here and to you as an
American are we not human being like
them like any other
persons 3 and half million Southern
Sudanese was slaughtered by the same
government and nobody said nothing
three and 3 and half
Millions where is Slaughter in the name
of Islam by the war as a Jihad because
that is what is being
designed since those 3 and a half
million happen to be Christians being
Slaughter under umbrella of Islam under
umbrella of SoCal Jihad
then who have an audacity to go and talk
about it because you don't want to be
accused you are
anti-islam 7 million Southern
Sudanese was
forced out of their country and become
refugees the biggest and the largest
refuges since World War
II and some of you probably become to
know the Lost Boys And The Lost Girl of
Sudan these are the peoples a tiny
people I call them
when their parent being perished they
Wonder walking from southern Sudan all
the way to Ethiopia and back to Kenya
and then they end up
here believe it or not if you find one
of them give yourself 5 minutes and let
them tell you what they went through
don't take it from
me these are the peoples that when I
goes to southern Sudan tell me that
Simon you
speaking on behalf of us because we
cannot have a chance the way you are you
are the lucky
victim and when you are standing up
against the MOs in New York being try to
be built on a ground zero you are
speaking on behalf of 13 million
Southern sud whom are saying no to that
most not to be built on the ground zero
because of if we
remember whatman said bring up bring
down a America and build the
Moses and you are absolutely
right my fellow human
being I'm not an enti
anything I have Muslims in my family
whom are being
forced to force islamization because
there are 3 million southern Sudan
Christians was forced convert to Islam
by force by the government in
kums the Islamic government Sudan is the
only Islamic country in the entire
Africa and when we talk about the BR
brutality come under the umbrella of
Islam
Sharia nobody know it better than the
people of southern Sudan because we went
through a
lot so for me to be given a chance to
speak of
course some others will say he's so
angry you damn right
yeah some will
say he doesn't know what you talk about
of course you right
again I was
robbed with from everything that a child
deserve to be and the child supposed to
learn from Mom and
Dad when I was 9 years old I was
kidnapped by a Muslim
person brought to a northern Sudan and
he went and give me a away to his
relative as a
gift that he came from southern Sudan
and he brought some
gift of course to most of
you you will be saying no that could not
be but
today you are hearing it from the same
person that happened to be a gift I'm
not ashamed to tell you that because if
I don't tell you it's not going to do me
any good it is inside me I better
release it
out maybe that will give me a comfort
when somebody say say to me
that I support you I admire your
work I was given away as a gift in which
that I was
forth as a child 9 years old to do the
work that being always done by the
donkey I was forced even not to be look
at myself as a human being because I was
not being considered as a human
being how do I know it because the
family himself or
them came to me that if I want to be
treated like a human being I have
options and that option is three one
convert to
Islam so that I will
be treated as a human being and I will
be taken to his schools
two pick the Arab name and the three
want he to become their
son of course as a human being to be
treated as a human being or to be looked
as a human being I did come close to
take
two Islam and Arab Nam but the difficult
part was how can I become their
son knowing what I'm going through every
day knowing that I have to be treated
worse than
animals I have to rely on
leftover I have to be bitten
constantly I know only one word yes and
yes to everything even kids will decide
to for fun come and say which is be the
slaves and they will gang on me like
playing
footballs and now they went to take all
rob me for my identity of course see I
cannot tell them no all I have to say I
will let you
know
hoping and
assuming that one day somebody may
come and realize that a child should not
go through what I'm going through I rely
on Hope and
patience patient in God that tomorrow
will be better than today
so people like me when they are being
given a chance to be speak especially
when it come to the crime being
committed under the Islamic law under
the Sharia law of
course I cannot
hesitate to come and tell the truth
because I'm
speaking on
behalf of 13 or 16 million Southern
sudanes who went through a
lot so my fellow human being and my
fellow
Americans living in a denier is not
going to help us in future living in a
den knowing that there is a big snakes
waiting to bite your child is not going
to help you wake up and wake up America
and thank you very much
we have a few minutes now if you have
any questions I don't know if we have a
microphone for you but uh please speak
up and uh we will uh repeat the
questions from here make sure you let us
know who you would like to answer the
question if you have anybody particular
in mind is that Rick in the back yeah
yeah I've been a candidate for the
United States Congress so I'm a
candidate for the United States Senate
here in Michigan I have been teaching
about Islam at every tea party at every
open event I get to no one else that I
know about not even Alan West beautiful
person that he is not even Sumi
wonderful person that she is that I
adore who else has the courage to openly
speak about Islam as has been taught
about this continent at this particular
place and why and this is to you Pamela
why is it that no other candidates that
no other politician s have the courage
to openly speak about this subject and
the threat that Islam is to this country
as well as to Canada as well as to
Europe as well as to the world why do
they not have the courage to do what I
do and what you do well first I'd like
to say vote for
Rick just briefly politicians are
looking in the rearview mirror they are
are absolutely not a reflection of
what's ahead uh the N media has been
completely co-opted the en media is self
enforcing the Sharia they will not
offend they will not criticize Islam
they are vicious when they don't like a
candidate vicious I mean did you see
this week you see Obama going after
Romney
donors that's an incredible I mean I
don't want to get into a political
discussion here but my point is is that
we need brave men like you and we need
to support brave men like Rick and
that's the only way you're going to get
things done because if he gets legs if
Rick gets legs they're going to go after
him fiercely and viciously to destroy
him I mean when Sarah Palin merely
tweeted you know about the ground zero
mosque you know being a stab in the
heart they went I mean it was it was
vicious it was a tsunami of um of bad
media the only good thing is I think
that the American people in in inly do
not do not trust the media I mean they
see that the media is just uh completely
and utterly corrupt and in the case of
Obama criminally negligent in not
vetting that candidate that that was my
first book The post- American
presidency yeah uh yes sir
yeah let this opportunity go by we have
a great panel here and uh we're looking
for
answers I'm a director of act for Canada
which is act for America in Toronto
chapter new chapter but I'm also
director of no Islam and schools and we
have a musketeer in
Toronto uh We've held uh demonstrations
on the steps of the torona school board
uh We've held protests in the streets
first time the media came up and we got
good media
exposure second time very few media EX
for Sun News Michael Corin uh covered it
uh after that nothing tenant
swindled how do we wake Canadians up and
how we can educate them because we're
going to use your resources and your
material because you you've laid the pth
open but what do we do now how do we
wake Canadians up Sun News is doing a
good job but not everybody watches Sun
News and so we need to wake Canadians up
we can educate them but we got to wake
them up first well how we going to wake
them up with the only way you wake
Canadians up is to have a Canadian team
to win the Stanley
Cup
but you know it it's not it's not look
you've got to remember that um and this
doesn't only apply to Islam this applies
to many of the Great issues social
issues such as marriage defending
marriage defending The Unborn most and
and I use a word um quite proudly most
normal people are raising their families
paying the bills being good citizens at
the end of a working day the last thing
they want to do is get involved
politically it's the um the strange ones
who go to the union meetings and and The
Fringe meetings I mean it is and and but
you know what they get things done so
let's not be too harsh on people who are
just exhausted at the end of their
working week however we have to be aware
and you know what's happening in the
west we're being killed with kindness
because even though we have this this
Rising tide of Islam which will not stop
it has no intention of stopping uh it
compromise is seen as victory
every every time we say let's sit down
and talk about this and maybe we can
work out a compromise they think that
they have
one people still have their very large
TV and their iPad and their iPod and
their their new car and their two
vacations and it's what sojja nipson was
talking about so many years ago don't
you understand you fools you're going to
lose everything cuz you're so
comfortable so I don't really have the
direct answer I think you do it one by
one by one by one anything you can do if
you can broadcast broadcast if you can
blog you blog if you can speak to
someone in the office speak to someone
in the office personal witness uh not in
an aggressive way reach out to people
whenever you can please never be
frightened I mean we've gone past that
surely I mean really you can be if you
really think that if you just hide away
it will all be okay we've learned
throughout history that is never the
solution to any response to evil so
that's what I would say but but don't
think by some Grand gesture some Grand
campaign we can change everything it's
going to be gradual just the way shall
we say the other side have won things
gradually we have to take them back
gradually well they're already parking
their cars outside our house yes sir
positive no about Canada from where we
sit over here it look like the canal
murders at least the final verdict was
well handled I compliment Ontario and
Canada for handling that question on on
Canada is it true that provincially
Ontario and Quebec had for a period of
maybe a decade a Sharia experiment that
they decided to end and did a one law
for all in those two provinces is that
correct uh first it's wonderful that in
a room full of Americans we were talking
about Canada I love
this the Canadian Empire is here to stay
get used to it learn French and
skate uh no that's not true there was
there was a um a provincial report from
a socialist uh state legislature if you
like a provincial MPP recommending
certain aspects of sharia law I think it
probably would have gone through but
there was enough popular protest that
the uh the
premier he probably wanted a b it but he
realized he couldn't and so he backed
down on that and in Quebec I look if
anywhere in Canada is going to respond
to all this it's Quebec um the French
aren't as nice as the English that's
just a fact yeah uh no you know I'm not
even trying to be flippant here you're
going to see this in Europe too that the
British the British tend to say oh well
it's okay you know we'll have a cup of
tea the French you said 20 look I don't
applaud the vote for the front National
even the Pen's daughter is not to be
trusted there're still a tinge of
fascism there however the 20% of people
who supported her in the presidential
election they're not fascists they're
just saying can you please try and deal
with Islam in our country please for
goodness sake there were French Jews
voting for her because she was a fascist
no enough is enough uh in Quebec you're
actually seeing some resistance now they
they are they play hard ball that's not
always positive sometimes it can exhibit
itself as racism but when it comes to
Islam I think they're saying we're not
going to stand for it so but that no
there's no real Sharia law in either
Province um but there'll be more
attempts to to install it there are
though polygamous marriages
certainly uh yes ma'am yes my question
is for the gentlem from Virginia um I
come from a city in Michigan that just
built to mosque last year but I didn't
start investigating Islam till just this
past February and I'm going back and
looking at the newspaper articles about
it and I'm seeing that the land was
donated uh they didn't mention the
funding they merged congregations with
Nation of
Islam how do I
investigate where the funding
came the first thing I would do is find
some friendly
Realtors uh in in your on your side and
talk with them they have the expertise
they can explain what the records are
and how to read them and everything else
we rely heavily on people like Denise
Lee who's sitting here from Virginia who
understands real
estate and uh and then we have
auctioneers who call us and tell us that
hey we had some of those people at our
auction today uh and we also have school
Headmasters now who will call us and say
they were in here trying to buy my
school with cash they'll come in with a
big a big bag of cash and try and buy
the school outright um that's what you
do and then you learn it as you go
through it my background is an
investigative reporting and I did a lot
of of this so I understand some of it
but it's not that hard if the
politicians can learn it you can and and
you just do that you just compile
details and then go after them with it
when you have it now where you take it
it's hard uh the media as pamelo says
the media isn't interested there's
always something wrong with your story
you know and uh and I would take it I
would go on the blogs and do the things
and make sure Pamela knows about it and
and just go at them heavily but but
don't give up and just you know just
keep on them that that muscaria story
really came up through the internet
really came up through the blogs yes you
had media there the first time because
it went so viral and then it got quiet
so what I mean every time the left does
a Rally or Islamic supremacists do a
rally they have five people there they
Triumph it they try it's a Triumph every
time even if it's just the mother and
the son and you have to do the same
thing you're not going to hit a home run
every single time so what and you send
us the pictures this is the stuff that
we traffic in we traffic in the news
that the the media will not report yes
Miss um to answer her question
Farmington public schools and a back
room deal Pamela you know about this cuz
we told you about it sold there an empty
school to the um I Islamic Cultural
Association in a back room deal no bids
never put it up for sale went back and
checked out the the deed go check the
deeds and see who holds it we found that
Nate was a deed holder of their other
school Huda School in Franklin we know
who they are care supported by care they
were supported by Care at the meeting we
were vilified um you you have to we have
a lawsuit we're on appeal yeah you just
have to go and check the records as was
said and see um who the people are and
what they're doing and it's you know
it's uh you know we we've we've been uh
one other thing we' we have done that we
also know that us uh a a local
conservative synagogue one of the
largest local conservative synagogues
invited Imam Mustafa elk to speak on on
the 10th anniversary of 9/11 they were
told we protested some of us are almost
arrested the ADL who's not our friend um
I'm the number one yeah the ADL even on
their own website talk about talks about
how anti- virulent he is how
anti-semitic he is and they still let
him in as a guest speaker on the beima
in in a conservative synagogue you just
have to get the word out it's going on
around here all the time and distribute
information that like that widely in in
Virginia we had had we had pictures of
uh the the Headmaster at the school and
his family they go out every weekend and
take pictures of the bridge supports
like the Chesapeake Bay Bridge and a lot
of the big Bridges and the Maryland
State Police got pictures of them on the
Chesapeake Bay Bridge and we took that
and we distributed it in about a five
mile radius around the different things
they were trying to do different
projects and it organized people it got
them really ril and and that's an
important part of what we're trying to
do is educate but also
mobilize yes ma'am thank you for your
patience thank you yes on the issue of
mobilizing and catalyzing we have an
opportunity here in Michigan to take
what has been imparted by this heroic
panel to try to impress upon our
governor and our state uh Senate and our
state house that it's time in Michigan
because Michigan is one of the states in
play as Pamela has mentioned that has
been trying to pass two measures two
compatible measures to in that's all
we're seeking to do is to insulate our
constitution to protect it from the
encroachment undermining and eventual
evisceration by uh the imposition of
foreign laws so I urge you to contact I
have a sheet if you're interested to
contact um it's being held up actually
they're trying to choke it back in
committee but it's being very
courageously spearheaded by
representative Dave Aima and by Senator
Roger Khan they need our support I've
got the numbers there's going to be an
important conference you mentioned the
center for security policy the vice
president will be one of the panelists
at this forum I urge you all to become
engaged and again to take the
information that we've learn and to to
to catalyze it into meaningful and
effective action and I wanted to ask you
can you tell us about the itna campaign
is taking place around the country
should try to um impede the efforts of
states that are trying to fight the
imposition of foreign law numbers is is
doing that there there are a number of
them that NOA is doing a a $3 million um
uh billboard campaign uh got sh you know
Sharia got questions get answers uh what
we've done is exactly that Islam ad that
was on uh Robert Muse's presentation I
didn't invent that ad okay the sun and
the grass and the trees I took their ad
come to Islam the exact same ad and flip
the language leaving Islam and so what I
did w was with with with um the Sharia
campaign Sharia got questions get
answers we did we mirrored the ad Sharia
um got got fatwa get answers uh call 1
800 live free and if you called the
number 18888 live free if you called the
number Robert Spencer answered okay um
it's a it's a propaganda campaign now I
again it got media it get getting media
is a way of getting the message out we
consider ourselves the work that I do is
like gorilla media that's what I do I
don't have $3 million I only bought one
city um but I yeah well you know but
Kansas City right across the right
across the street Sharia got questions
Sharia God fatwa you understand a little
inside baseball it torments them um but
it also it also removes The Sting from
what they're doing this is what we have
to do you don't need a lot of money and
each one of you are your own oneman
media organizations you have email lists
you have friends you do things uh you
play tennis titly Winks I don't know
what normal people do I just work all
the time but you meet people and you
talk to people now you can't always
reach everybody there are people that
are married to their dog but last week
we were at Temple University uh non
Simon Robert uh Islamic apartheid week
and I will tell you it was a zoo if you
want to see what's going on it will
shock you to your to your core of what's
going on on college campuses it's
complete fascism I mean they came in
they took 75% of the seats the people
that really wanted to hear us speak
could not get in they were ridiculed and
made fun of by these protesters by these
fascists these Jack Boots and yet even
at the end a girl came up to me and said
I just want you to know I was here with
the opposition but I stayed and you you
flip me you turn me now what what this
girl is going to do in her life you you
don't understand your power you don't
understand your influence uh you there's
never going to be CBS News where you
reach millions of people but you throw
that Pebble in and you have no idea the
ripples how many people you reach you
have no idea how powerful you are and
you have to exert that power now you
have to I want to say one other thing
how fortunate we are in Michigan because
leading the Vanguard in this law fair
Arena we have the Thomas moreal Law
Center based in an arbor yes
[Applause]
forunate I know that they have worked
with you but in in leading the fight in
this effort we have time for just one
more oh sorry you know that whole
program it's it's really it's an
information operation program what
they're what they're trying to do and
and one of the with the the American
Freedom law and I'm I'm in Ann Arbor
Michigan here as well in fact I used to
be the senior councel at Thomas Moore
for 12 years and I started up the
American Freedom law CER with my
colleague David Yami who is truly the
the expert in this area and uh Frank
Gaffney from the center of security
policy is on our Advisory Board and one
of the things that he's done is I I
mentioned briefly he created this this
uh education program a video education
program so you can be educated about
truly what the Muslim brotherhood's
about what sh is about it's a video
program we've got it posted up on our
website right now the the first in our
featured media uh American Freedom law
center.org so that's a a a great
resource for you to be able to counter
this information operation that is uh
that's going
on Mr Muse what are the numbers of the
legislation in the state house and state
senate here in
Michigan okay you can speak to the lady
here and she'll have those list that one
more sir in the middle
there yes uh good evening it's a
thrill
I'm second thing I wanted to mention was
that the BS serious story was uh broken
by my friend blazing caner who sitting
in the
back my question goes to uh
mrcy uh your president has said
something about um wanting to
Institute uh un resolutions and laws
about human rights and enshrine them
within the laws here in the United true
now does that have any LS to It
Whatever
agenda I don't
know who's that
to who are you asking is that to me who
are you asking
please the lawyer that's you oh Muse you
want you want to hear from
me well I mean certainly the courts and
and some justices as we've seen in the
Supreme Court have been looking to
international law to make determinations
but it our constitution specifically has
a supremacy clause and in that supremacy
clause it makes the US Constitution the
supreme law of the land and so these
other other foreign laws cannot trump
our fundamental constitutional rights
should not trump our fundamental
constitutional rights but if you
remember uh uh justice Ginsburg recently
gave a uh an interview when she was
louing a you know a foreign Constitution
over the US Constitution South Africa so
I mean Technic under our constitution
it's the supreme law of the land and
these other laws cannot Trump those
rights but uh it depends on who the
justices are and uh elections have
consequences in terms of who's going to
be on the bench so if you have concerns
about foreign laws you ought to ensure
that you uh you vote for presidents who
want to put uh justices on the bench who
are want to stick to our US Constitution
the text of the Constitution and not
look Beyond to these foreign laws but it
can't Trump a a statute itself or
anything else cannot trump our
constitution supreme law on the
land thank you all so much for coming
don't waste what you have learned here
don't waste what you have heard here you
all are the soldiers in this battle as
Pamela always says whenever we're
speaking I hear her say this I'm going
to say it now this is a war that is not
going to be fought on
battlefields this is a war for our
Justice our freedom and for human rights
it is a war not with guns and bombs it
is a war in our communities and we are
the soldiers it is up to us
I want to thank you all for coming it
was really thrilling you give us all
hope um Michael will be outside signing
his book for purchase yes Michael um my
books are outside if you need any advice
on something feel free to come to us and
remember if you're working on something
send it to the blogs we get it out there
and we get it done fight the great fight
you